Rồi các bạn, hôm qua chúng ta đã cùng
nhau chúng ta viết được một cái đoạn
script để chúng ta huấn luyện một cái mô
hình giúp chúng ta dự đoán xem một người
người ta có bị người ta có bị tiểu đường
hay không đúng không? Hôm qua mình quên
có một cái đoạn mình quên các bạn là gì?
[hắng giọng] Mình chưa in the ra cho bạn
cái predict này đúng không? Hôm qua
chúng ta đây nhá. Mình tắt đoạn này đi
này nhá. Đúng không? Hôm qua chúng ta
làm cái gì nhỉ? Chúng ta à chúng ta đọc
dữ liệu vào này đúng không? Chúng ta đọc
dữ liệu vào. Xong chúng ta bắt đầu chúng
ta sẽ tách dữ liệu. Tách dữ liệu chúng
ta tách theo chiều dọc trước. X sang bên
Y sang ở bên rồi chúng ta tách theo
chiều ngang. Xe X test Y trên Y test
tách như này. Được chưa? Chúng ta tiền
xí dữ liệu. Tiền xí xong chúng ta bắt
đầu chúng ta khởi tạo mô hình. Khởi tạo
mô hình xong chúng ta bắt đầu chúng ta
đem mô hình ch đi huấn luyện với dòng
model.fit này. Sau chúng ta đem mô hình
đi dự đoán model predict này. Được chưa?
Hôm qua mình quên mình chưa cho in cho
các bạn xem cái predict trông nó như thế
nào.
[hắng giọng] In PR này nhá
các bạn nhìn này. Yck này đây nó như thế
này. Được chưa? I break này. Thế đây cái
dự đoán được chưa? Thì tất nhiên chúng
ta có cho có thể in in nếu mà để cho nó
dễ nhìn chúng ta sẽ in đồng thời y cả
ghi cả cái y dự đoán với y thực tế đúng
không? Thì mình sẽ làm nào? Nhìn nhá.
Nếu mà bây giờ mình muốn in hai cái này
cạnh nhau để nhìn nó dễ nhá. Thì các bạn
nhìn này for e j này in zip mình zip thì
Ix
này
với cả
test nhá. Được chưa?
Này edition này
value này
như này nhá. Nhìn này.
Ừ. Đây các bạn nhìn này.
Đây là cái dự đoán đúng không? Không là
người ta khỏe mạnh, tức là không là
người ta không bị tiểu đường và một là
người ta bị tiểu đường. Đúng không?
Chúng ta in ra song này. Đúng không? Tất
nhiên là in ra này thì nhìn nó sẽ hơi
khó đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ phải tính ra
cho chúng tính ra cái report này nhìn nó
sẽ tổng quát hơn đúng không? Thế hôm
quay cái chúng ta là chúng ta dừng ở đây
đúng không? Đây cái report này đúng
không?
Chết rồi. Nhầm
nhầm đi bug bạn chờ tí nhá.
Đi nhá.
Đây cái này gọi là cái classification
report đúng không? Hôm qua mình nói rồi
sẽ có những cái cột như là precision
này, recolle này, F1 này, support này.
Support là số lượng simple.
Ờ cái bộ test này thì nó có 154 sample.
Ờ tổng cộng cho nó thì có 100 cho class
số 0 và 54 cho class số 1. Được chưa?
Thế và đây là quyển th F1 cho từng class
một đúng không? Cái dòng đầu tiên là khi
mà bạn coi class số 0 là class positive
còn cái dòng ở dưới là các bạn coi class
số 1 là class positive đúng không? Đây
là accuracy. Accuracy xong thì các bạn
có trung bình không trọng số và trung
bình có trọng số này. Được chưa? Trung
bình không trọng số, trung bình có trọng
số. Thì thông thường các bạn chỉ một cái
c report này là là ok rồi. Được chưa?
Thế thì bây giờ các bạn mình hỏi các bạn
thêm nhá. Chúng ta vẫn chưa tối ưu gì
đúng không? Chưa hề tối ưu gì. Nhưng mà
trước khi tối ưu chúng ta có một vài cái
nữa chúng ta cần phải xem xét. Bây giờ
các bạn nhìn này. Bây giờ đây là cái
classific report đúng không? Bây giờ nếu
mà tôi muốn biết cụ thể xem xem là ở đây
mình chỉ có hai class thôi, số 0, số 1
đúng không? Dự đoán đúng thì không nói
làm gì. Dự đoán sai nó chỉ có hai kiểu
là gì? là những cái sample thuộc class
số 0 nhưng mà mô hình nó lại dự đoán là
số 1 và ngược lại đúng không? Nó chỉ có
hai kiểu thôi. Một là ông ông là số 0
nhưng tôi dự là số 1 hoặc là ông là số 1
nên tôi dự là số 0. Nó chỉ có một trong
hai kiểu đấy thôi. Thì bây giờ nếu mình
muốn cụ thể xem là trong cái bộ rượu
này, trong bộ test này có bao nhiêu
sample thuộc class số 0 bị dự án thành
số 1 hoặc là bao nhiêu sample thuộc
class số 1 mà bị dán thành số 0. Thì
theo các bạn chúng ta làm bằng là thế
nào bây giờ? Chúng ta dựa vào cái gì?
Bây giờ mình muốn biết là có bao nhiêu
không? Có bao nhiêu sample số 0 bị dưỡn
nhầm thành 1 và bao nhiêu simple số 1 bị
dán nhầm thành 0 thì mình dựa vào cái gì
bây giờ? Cái bảng này nó sẽ không cho
mình biết cái điều đấy đúng không? Cái
bảng này nó sẽ không cho mình biết cái
điều đấy. Thật ra là
thật ra là tính được tính được nhưng mà
ngồi tính đây nó sẽ hơi mất công một
chút. Có cách nào để tôi có thể tôi à
đúng rồi giờ vào confusion magic.
Confusion magic. Confusion magic nó sẽ
một cái ma trận, một cái mảng hai chiều
kích thước 2 x2 đúng không? Hàng là thực
tế, cột là dự đoán. Đó mình confusion
magic này.
Confusion magic nhá. In ra động y trang
đây rồi.
Confusion magic nhá. Nhìn này.
Đây được chưa? Hàng là thực tế cột dự
đoán đúng không? Class số 0 đây đúng
không? Trong a trong 100 s class số 0
thì có 90 cái dượn đúng và 10 cái bị dấn
thành class số 1. Trong số 54 cá số 1
thì có 24 ông bị nhầm thành số 0 đúng
không? Đường cho chính là dựa án đúng
này. Được chưa? Đây là cái chúng ta dừng
ở hôm qua. Dừng ở hôm qua đúng không?
Nhìn chung thì mô hình nó cũng ok đúng
không? Và các bạn có thể các bạn hoàn
toàn các bạn thay đổi mô hình. Như Ở đây
tôi dùng random press chẳng hạn đúng
rồi.
Tôi có cái random state đây để tôi để
tôi có thể cố định cái sự ngẫu nhiên của
tôi phải không? Tại vì trong đ chúng ta
có cái boost shopping chúng ta lấy mẫu
có hoàn lại ấy là nó sẽ có cái phần ngẫu
nhiên. Đây tôi cố định như này được
chưa? Nhìn qua thì cũng ok đúng không?
Mô hình nó cũng dự đoán một cái được một
cái gì đấy. Được chưa?
mô hình nó cũng dự đoán được một cái gì
đấy. Thế thì đây là chúng ta viết trong
quá trình chuyên đúng không? Nó chạy nó
chạy và nó dự đoán được đúng không? Nó
chạy và dự án được. Thế nhưng mà bây giờ
thì tôi sẽ
muốn nghĩ đến việc là tôi sẽ
tôi sẽ cải thiện nó. Tôi sẽ cải thiện
nó. Tôi cải thiện bằng cách nào? Bây giờ
nhìn qua nhá. Theo các bạn bây giờ nếu
mình muốn cải thiện theo các bạn chúng
ta có thể làm cái gì? Bây giờ tôi có một
cái baseline này rồi đúng không? một cái
mô hình như này. Rồi bây giờ tôi muốn
cải thiện đi. Theo các bạn chúng ta có
thể làm những cái gì?
Nếu bảo muốn cải thiện thì tôi có thể
làm cái gì? Bây giờ
theo các bạn mình có thể làm cái gì? Các
bạn nghĩ về cái gì? Chúng ta có thể làm
cái gì bây giờ nhỉ?
Với cái trường hợp bộ rượu này với cái
bài toán như này. Bây giờ bảo cải thiện
đi đúng không? Tôi có một cái B sa rồi
tôi muốn làm tốt hơn. Theo bạn chúng ta
có thể làm cái gì nào?
Các bạn nghĩ đến cái gì?
Ví dụ đi. Ví dụ nhá. Mình mình mình thu
về phạm vi cho các bạn nhá. Ví dụ bây
giờ với cùng cái mô hình random fred này
đi đúng không? Với random fred này. Bây
giờ các bạn muốn cải thiện cái mô hình
random fres này theo các bạn các bạn sẽ
làm cái gì?
Rầm Fred nhá. Nhìn này.
Đầu tiên cũng phải biết random fr nó có
nó có cái gì đúng không? Này fred nhá.
Random forest bạn truy random for trong
sách cái l nó sẽ có hai phiên bản. Một
là cho bài toán classification nó là đây
đúng không? Còn cho bài toán re ở dưới
đúng không? Nhưng mà đây mình là
classification thì mình thế này thôi.
Được chưa? Hôm qua mình nói các bạn rồi
đúng không? Thì ờ thì thì thông thường
ấy khi mà các bạn đọc những cái doc
documentation về những cái class này ấy
bao giờ cũng thế các bạn nó sẽ có cái
phần tên là phần khai báo nhá được chưa
phần mô tả nhá được chưa nó sẽ có một
vài những cái tham số ở đây không phải
một vài mà tất cả tham số đều ở đây và
thông thường những cái tham số quan
trọng nhất nó sẽ ở trên cùng với random
fred nhá tham số đầu tiên là gì là số
lượng cây and estimat đây chính là số
lượng cây mặc định là 100 tức là nếu các
bạn không thay đổi gì nó sẽ cho đúng 100
này. Cái thứ hai là carian. Criterian nó
là cái gì? Nó chính là cái các bạn dùng
cái gì để các bạn tính đánh đánh giá cái
độ tốt của các cái nốt để chia đấy. Mặc
định nó là cái gini index nọ chúng ta
học đấy. Đúng không? Ngoài ra chúng ta
có một vài khác entropy block loss mà
mặt bản chất chúng nó dư nhau. Tức là
gì? Cái điểm nó càng bé thì càng tốt.
Max dep là cái gì? Max là max là cái độ
sâu tối đa của cây. Nếu mà để non ấy,
mặc định là non ấy thì cây nó sẽ được mở
rộng đến khi nào mà cái nốt cái cái cái
nốt lái nó hoàn toàn nó lệch hết về về
một phía. Đây này. Đây không pure tức là
nó lệch hết về một phía. Tức là nó chỉ
có sle một class thôi. Hoặc là khi mà
cái tất cả nút lá ấ nó có dưới min
sample phần tử này. Min sample split này
mặc định nó là 2. Tức là nếu nốt lá nó
có hai phần tử trở xuống tôi sẽ không
split nữa. Còn trên hai tôi vẫn split
tiếp. Đúng không? Min semble split này,
mean symbol left này. Tôi tức là có bao
còn bao nhiêu sle thì tôi vẫn tiếp tục
tôi tách này đúng không? Lá phải có tối
nh bao nhiêu sle nhưng mà thông thường
thì hai cái quan trọng hai cái đầu tiên
là hai cái quan trọng nhất. Số lượng cây
và cái chion thông thường là hai này là
cái quan trọng nhất còn mấy cái dưới các
bạn dùng mặc định cũng được. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ với cùng cái mô hình random
for này, nếu tôi muốn cải thiện cái mô
hình random fr này, theo các bạn cái
việc dễ nhất tôi có thể làm là tôi làm
cái gì?
Cái việc dị nhất tôi có thể làm với m
này là là tôi làm cái gì các bạn?
Mình muốn thử cải thiện nó làm thế nào?
Mình muốn cải thiện đồng FR các bạn làm
thế nào? Ừ, thay đổi số cây hay tổng
quát hơn là chúng ta sẽ làm cái gì các
bạn?
Thay đổi số cây là một trường hợp riêng.
Tổng quát hơn chúng ta sẽ làm cái gì?
Tổng quát hơn chúng ta sẽ làm cái gì các
bạn?
Ừ đúng rồi. Dùng từ đúng rồi. High
parameter turning. Đúng rồi. High
parameter turning. Tức là chúng ta sẽ
file tun cái seram số. Si số chính a này
những cái này chính là si âm số này.
Được chưa? Tức là gì? Không phải dạng số
cây mà gì? Tức là gì? Tôi sẽ thử các cái
giá trị số cây khác nhau và tôi cũng có
thể tôi thử các cái giá trị cition khác
nhau. Ví dụ số lượng cây các bạn thử là
50 100 cây. Criterian các bạn thử là
gini enty với lost. Thế tổng cộng các
bạn nếu mà như vậy các bạn sẽ có tổng
cộng bao nhiêu bao nhiêu tổ hợp tổng
cộng?
Ông trên này có ba giá trị ông dưới này
có ba giá trị. Tổng hợp các tổng cộng
các bạn có bao nhiêu tổ hợp các bạn?
Giả sử trên này các bạn thử 50 100 đây
các bạn thử gini entropy block loss t
các bạn sẽ có bao nhiêu tổ hợp
hai
ơ
chín đúng không ờ này có cái gì đâu các
bạn chín tổ hợp đúng không hôm này có ba
hôm này có ba kết đầu lại có chín tổ hợp
đúng không thế thì tất nhiên các bạn
cũng có thể các bạn hoàn toàn là ừ đấy
đúng không bây giờ viết này nhìn Xố nh l
dòng nhìn nó nhìn nó dễ nhá
nhá đúng không? Đấy nên estimate nhá 100
được chưa? Criterian bằng à chưa được
bằng à mini
ví dụ như vậy đúng không? Quá thử thì tổ
v nhau thế nhưng mà ờ
đây tôi thử th 50 này 100 200 rồi dưới
gini lớp đu nhưng mà thử này thì thủ
công quá đúng thử này thì thủ công quá
thử này nó thủ công quá thứ nhất là nó
thủ công đúng không các bạn có thể thay
50 này các bạn ghi lại nhá 100 này xong
các bạn ghi lại nhá đúng không xong lại
200 ghi lại xong lại đổi đây đúng không
các bạn lại phải ghi lại chín tổ hợp
khác nhau đúng không rất là mất mất thời
gian. Nó rất là mất thời gian.
Thế thì bây giờ ấy làm thủ công này thì
thường trong tự đấy người ta sẽ không ai
người ta làm như này cả. Người ta xem
một cách khác nó tự động hóa hơn. Xem
sách cái lơn ấy người ta hỗ trợ chúng ta
là gì? Nó sẽ hỗ trợ chúng ta có thể
chúng ta test nhanh chóng không phải
nhanh chóng, chúng ta sẽ test các cái tổ
hợp khác nhau mà chúng ta muốn đúng
không? Chúng ta sẽ chỉ ra là với mỗi một
cái th với một cái tham số ở đây tôi
muốn thử các cái giá trị gì. Sau đó thì
nó sẽ thử cho các bạn tất cả những cái
tổ hợp có thể có được tạo ra từ những
cái bộ xố mà các bạn vừa chỉ ra. Được
chưa? Thế thì trong sách ken ấy có một
cái class nó giúp chúng ta làm cái việc
này người ta gọi là green search.
Green search là cái gì? Green. Green nó
là green nó là cái giống kiểu cái vỉ
nướng thịt ấy hoặc là nó là giống kiểu
cái mặt vợt ấy. Nó nó có các cái đường
kẻ sọc kẻ ngang đấy. Nó là green. Đây
này. Mình cũng chả biết tiếng Việt gọi
là cái gì. Cái cái mạng lưới cái đây
này. Cái lưới cái lưới đúng r nó như
này. Đấy. Win nó như này. Được chưa?
[khịt mũi] Thế thì bây giờ cái win này ấ
ờ tôi sẽ tôi sẽ khai báo là tôi muốn thử
các cái giá trị cái xâm số nào và sau đó
thì nó sẽ thử tất cả những cái tổ hợp
của tôi. Dùng rất là dễ thôi nhá. Mình
sẽ thử các bạn xem nhá. Đầu tiên này.
Đầu tiên các bạn muốn dùng nó thì các
bạn phải chỉ ra là các bạn muốn thử cái
gì. Được chưa nhá. Thì bây giờ
ờ đầu tiên này các bạn sẽ phải chỉ ra là
ừ
đây các bạn sẽ dù nhá param này nhá cái
dictionary này được chưa
ví dụ là các bạn muốn thử về random fred
được chưa random fres nó có cái gì
random fred nó có nó có số lượng cây số
lượng cây này có số lượng cây nhá được
chưa cây này mình sẽ dùng cái đây là một
cái dictionary đúng không key là tên của
cái paramet Còn value là các cái giá trị
các bạn muốn thử 50 100 200 được chưa?
Một này. Thứ hai là gì? Cái criterian
quaran các bạn sẽ thử gopy với block
loss. Các bạn ghi hết vào đây. Log los
ví dụ như vậy nhá.
Được chưa? Thế tôi muốn thử hà này thì
bây giờ tôi sẽ tôi sẽ dùng green search
để tôi để tôi thử. Các bạn nhìn này. Cái
green search ấy nó lại giúp các bạn thử
vét cạn tất cả các cái tổ hợp các bạn
chỉ ra. Được chưa? Green search dùng rất
là dễ thôi. Đầu tiên nhá mình đầu tiên
này mình sẽ import nó này. Model
selection nhá.
Đây green search nhá.
Đây nhá. Green search này nhá.
Đây được chưa? Thế bây gi ở dưới mình sẽ
không khai báo cái mô hình riêng lẻ nữa
mà mình sẽ dùng green search. Mình green
search nhá.
À bây giờ model của mình sẽ này. Model
mình sẽ bằng resarch này. Được chưa?
Mình sẽ chèn mình sẽ ở bên trong mình sẽ
bắt đầu mình khai báo này. Đầu tiên là
mình phải khai báo cái mô hình của mình.
Random forest này. Được chưa? Random for
như này. Và mình sẽ phải khai báo cái
random state này để cho nó cố định này.
Random
state bằng
100 đi. Ví dụ như vậy được chưa? Nó làm
set như này. Được chưa? Đây là cái tham
số đầu tiên. Tham số thứ hai là các bạn
sẽ phải đưa vào cái param của các bạn.
Cái param green này. Đấy chính là cái
dictionary mà các bạn vừa khai báo. Đấy
được chưa? Đây cho mình nhìn nhá. Đầu
tiên là cái estimeter chính là cái mô
hình này. Đây là cái mô hình các bạn đưa
vào. Cái prime green chính là cái cái tổ
hợp mà các bạn vừa chỉ ra. Đấy. Tôi muốn
thử số lượng cây là 50 100. Tôi muốn thử
qutarient là gini entropy lop lot. Nó sẽ
có tổng hợp chín tổ hợp tổng cộng. Được
chưa? Chín tổ hợp. Thế các bạn nhìn này.
Thế bây giờ nhá hôm qua các bạn có nhớ
là mình nói về cái KFO cross validation
đúng không? Case cross version là cái kỹ
thuật để giúp chúng ta có thể chúng ta
tận dụng chúng ta tối ưu hóa chúng ta
tối đa hóa dữ liệu dành cho bộ train
đúng không? Dành cho bộ trin. Thế thì ở
đây chúng ta sẽ áp dụng green search.
Thế thì khi mà các bạn muốn áp dụng
green search ấy các bạn sẽ phải chỉ ra
là cái số k nó bằng bao nhiêu trong cái
gre này cái số k ấy nó đây này nó là CV
này. CV là l tắt của cross validation nó
chính là cái số k đấy. Nếu các bạn không
chỉ ra cái số này thì nó sẽ mặc định là
nó sẽ lấy k là bằng 5. Còn nếu các bạn
chỉ ra là sẽ lấy cái số k tùy theo các
bạn chỉ. Ví dụ mình dùng muốn dùng k = 6
đi đúng không? Trong này người ta không
gọi là K, người ta gọi là CV. CV bằng 6
đi. Đấy thì các bạn nhớ không? Hôm qua
chúng ta bằng 6 có nghĩa là gì?
Bằng 6 có nghĩa là
bằng 6 có nghĩa là đúng không? Mình nói
lại nhá. Hôm qua bộ test là tách riêng
ra rồi đúng không? Còn cái bộ trên thôi.
Bộ trên thì k = 6 nhá. K = 6 đúng không?
Thì có vẻ các bạn sẽ chia làm k = 6 thì
hơi nhiều bằng 4 đi đúng không? Nhớ hôm
qua đây 4 và như này đúng không? làm điu
lạnh ủ bốn lần như này đấy.
Đấy
đúng không? Đấy thì lần lần đầu đây là
bộ va bộ va bộ va bộ va do tính trung
bình lại là xong được chưa? Đây gọi là
cf cross validation. Sau lần cuối các
bạn sẽ huấn luyện lại một lần nữa với
toàn bộ dữ liệu tất cả dành cho bộ trên
đấy thì làm thế này tôi vừa dùng toàn bộ
dữ liệu để dành cho bộ tren được và tôi
vẫn có cái cơ chế để tôi đánh giá mô
hình của tôi một cách rất là phe đúng
không? Thế thế thì cái CV này các bạn
chỉ ra k bằng mấy đúng không? mặc định
bằng 5 đây mình chỉ ra bằng 6. Thế tiếp
theo các bạn chú ý này. Thì bây giờ ấy
cái ý tưởng là gì? Là bây giờ tôi sẽ
dùng tôi sẽ dùng tôi sẽ dùng KF cross
function để tôi test xem là chín cái tổ
hợp này. Chín cái tổ hợp bao gồm là ba
ông này, ba ông này là có chín tổ hợp
đúng không? Tôi sẽ xem là chín tổ hợp
này tổ hợp nào là tổ hợp tốt nhất?
Được chưa? Tôi hãy thử xem là chín tổ
hợp này tổ hợp nào là tổ hợp tốt nhất?
Thế nhưng bây giờ một cái vấn đề nảy
sinh là gì? Là tốt nhất dựa vào cái gì?
Tại vì sao? Tại vì với bài toán phân
loại các bạn có rất nhiều cách bạn đánh
giá một mô hình. Các bạn có thể đánh giá
dựa vào accuracy, precision, recall, F1.
Thì bây giờ các bạn sẽ phải chỉ ra là
gì? Là bây giờ các bạn muốn đánh giá các
cái tổ hợp này của tôi dựa theo tiêu chí
gì? dựa theo prion hay recall hay là ac
ở đây các bạn sẽ có một cái tham số tên
là scoring. Scoring bình thường với bài
toán phân loại nếu các bạn không chỉ ra
cái scoring này mặc định nó sẽ lấy
accuracy đúng không? Nhưng mà tất nhiên
là mình không phải lúc nào mình cũng
muốn lấy accuracy đúng không? Thế về cái
scoring thì làm như nào? Thì các bạn
nhìn này, mình sẽ dựa vào ví dụ cách dễ
là sẽ dùng cái tên đây này nhá. Nếu các
bạn muốn dùng accuracy thì các bạn dùng
cái tên này accuracy được chưa? Muốn
dùng F1 score đây F1 được chưa? Pion
recall đây lại như vậy được chưa? Thế ví
dụ đây mình muốn dùng F1 đi được chưa?
Ví dụ đây mình mua d F1 đi thì mình đây
nhá scoring nếu các bạn không chỉ ra gì
là nó sẽ lấy ac còn đây mình sẽ ghi là
F1 được chưa f1 đấy được chưa cái mô
hình mà tôi muốn áp dụng green search
này các cái tổ hợp tham số mà tôi muốn
thử này K là bằng bao nhiêu này trong
cây focus validation này dựa theo cái
điểm gì t tôi tôi xem là chín cái tổ hợp
này cái tổ hợp nào có cái điểm F tốt
nhất được chưa đấy xem còn cái gì nữa
Không.
Rồi còn một cái nữa là verbal. Verbow là
cái gì? Cái từ này tiếng Việt mình nghĩa
là gì các bạn? Verb tiếng Việt nghĩa là
gì? Verbal tiếng Việt nghĩa là gì các
bạn?
Verb tiếng Việt là gì các bạn?
Vâ v tiếng Việt nghĩa là gì?
L mình yên lặng đây nhỉ.
Dài dòng dườm già đúng không? Verbow
nghĩa là dài dòng dườm già. Cái verbow
này nó sẽ control cái việc là những cái
thông điệp nó in ra màn hình nhiều hay
ít. Nếu các bạn để số một nó sẽ in ra ít
thôi. Các bạn để số càng to nó in ra
càng lắm. Nên thường nó để số hai nó in
ra rất là nhiều thứ. Được chưa? Ví dụ
mình để verb mình để bằng 2 nhá. Các bạn
nhìn thấy nó sẽ in ra rất là nhiều thứ
này nhá. V bảng 2 nhá. Ví dụ như vậy
nhá. Thế bây giờ khi mà mình dùng
resarch này mình vẫn fit bình thường.
Vẫn viết bình thường. Thế nhưng mà các
bạn nhìn nhá sau cái trình chạy nó sẽ in
ra rất nhiều thứ. Các bạn nhìn này. K là
bằng 6. Mình có chín tổ hợp tổng cộng
đúng không? 9 x 6 = 54 thì nó sẽ có tổng
cộng là nó sẽ có tổng cộng là 54 cái ph
như này. Cứ sáu cái là là cho một tổ
hợp. Được chưa? Nhìn này. Nhạy thử nhá.
Nhìn này các bạn nhìn này. Đấy đúng
không? Six f. 6 này được chưa? 9
candidate. Tại vì sao? Tại vì đây 3/3
bằng 9 mà. Được chưa? Tổng có 54 cái
fit. Như thế cứ sáu cái fit là của một
tổ hợp đây này. Sáu cái một tổ hợp đây.
Ví dụ đây tổ hợp là 50 cây với cả Gini
được chưa? 100 cây với cả Gini.
200 cây với cả Gini. Được chưa? 50 cây
với cả Entropi.
100 cây với entropy. 200 cây với Entropy
vân vân. Được chưa? Đấy các cái tổ hợp
như vậy. Thế được chưa? Và đến cuối thì
sau khi chúng ta chạy xong cái cái dòng
này ấy thì mặc định là gì? Là là là là
cái model này nó sẽ giữ lại cái tổ hợp
tốt nhất. Thế nhưng mà ở đây mình lại
mình lại mình lại chưa in cái gì ra cả
đúng không? Nó nhẽ là mình phải in ra
sau sau cái dòng này ấ sau cái dòng số
38 ấy thì mặc định là nó sẽ giữ lại cái
tổ hợp tốt nhất. Thế bây giờ giả sử mình
muốn biết xem là cái tổ hợp tốt nhất này
nó là tổ hợp nào thì mình sẽ phải in ra
một vài thứ. Các bạn nhìn nhá. Và cái
green search này nhá. Nó có một cái
attribute này các bạn có thể in ra cái
đây là cái best model. Cái best model
các bạn không cần in tại vì là các bạn
chứa một model thôi. Các bạn chứa một
model là random forest thôi thì in the
best nó cũng ra cái mô hình này thôi.
Quan trọng là gì? Mình muốn biết cái tổ
hợp thứ nhất là là tổ hợp nào và cái và
cái score lớn nhất à score tốt nhất là
bao nhiêu đúng không? Tức là trong số 9
ông này ông nào là ông có cái điểm văn
tốt nhất. Thế thì muốn quan tâm này best
score với cả best param. Mình in ra thử
nhá các bạn. Nhìn này. Green này. Model
này. Chấm best score trước đi. Best
score score này và best param nhá. Cho
bạn xem thử này. Mình vẫn để v bằng 2.
Bây giờ nếu mình nếu mình để bằng 2 nó
sẽ in ra rất nhiều. Tí mình cho các bạn
xem v = 1 nó sẽ in ra ít hơn.
[khịt mũi]
Đấy.
Được chưa?
[khịt mũi]
Đây các bạn nhìn này. Trong số 9 tổ hợp
này tổ hợp tốt nhất là tổ hợp mà các bạn
dùng pi kết hợp với 50 cây là tốt nhất.
Và cái số điểm F1 tốt nhất là 63,05 điểm
đúng 0,6305. Được chưa? 0,6305. Đấy. Sau
thì tôi lại ngồi in bình thường thôi.
Đây các bạn chú ý này. Đây chính là cái
lý do mà vì sao lúc ban đầu ấy mình
không chia thành bộ trên với mình không
mình không có bộ va. Tại vì khi các bạn
dùng cái resort này ấy là bộ van nó đã
nằm ở bên trong rồi đúng không? Bộ va nó
ẩn ở bên trong bộ tren rồi. Được chưa?
Thế mà mình in đầy đủ này. Chạy lại này.
Dạ nhá. Nếu các bạn thấy in nhiều quá
thì các bạn cho cái verb nó bé đi. Đây
vâ bằng 1 này nó sẽ in ra ít thôi. Bằng
1 này in ra ít lắm.
Đấy nó nó chỉ in ra mỗi dòng đầu thôi.
Nó không in ra cái râu rì không phải nó
không bước thành phần nữa.
Đây các bạn nhìn thấy kết quả đây. Kết
quả đây
đây vẫn op 50k đúng không? Đây kết quả
tốt nhất đây.
Rồi các bạn đến bước này có ai có câu
hỏi gì không?
Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Nào có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Các bạn có gì các bạn chưa clear các bạn
các bạn các bạn nói ra nhá không thì
mình không mình không biết được là các
bạn có hiểu đến đâu không nhá. Có gì
thắc mắc cứ hỏi đừng có ngại nhá.
Thế các bạn cho mình hỏi này, thế việc
các bạn không hỏi thì mình hỏi. Ở trên
đây mình in ra cái score là 0,630
là cái F1 score đúng không? Nhưng mà ở
dưới này thì đây là F1 score của class
số 1. Class số 1 là class positive. Thế
nhưng mà ở dưới này thì các bạn thấy là
cái FC con này là 0 phẩ
ở trên là 0,63 dưới là 0,61 khác nhau
này.
Ô mình vừa hôm qua mình vừa giải thích
rồi. Vì sao mà random fred chạy lần nào
kết quả nó cũng giống nhau hả các bạn?
Hôm qua vừa giải thích xong. Vì sao mà
random fres lần nào chạy nó cũng giống
lần nào hả các bạn? Vì phải có random
state.
>> Ừ đúng rồi. Có random state rồi đúng
không? Vì mình cố định nó rồi chứ không
có cái dòng này là mỗi lần chạy ra một
kết quả.
Được chưa? Còn cái average kia nó có cái
gì đâu các bạn ở đây bốn cái nó ra cái
eros chạ hoặc là nó ra cái aquasi cộng
trung bình lại là xong. Avest av nghĩa
là trung bình mà điểm trung bình của bốn
người là bốn người cộng lại chia chia
cho 4. Điểm trung bình của 50 người là
50 người cộng lại chia cho 5. Thì đây có
bốn cái bốn cái này cộng lại chia cho 4
đúng không? Ví dụ k = 4 chẳng hạn, mỗi
ông này ra một cái lót chẳng hạn, cộng
lại chia 4 ra cái lót trung bình đúng
không? Trung bình thì nó sẽ là trung
bình thì nó là trung bình thôi đúng
không? Trung bình là cộng lại và chia
cho đầu người thôi đúng không? Đúng rồi.
Chiều này là của F1 chính xác. Đấy mình
dùng cái score này đúng không? Chính là
nó đấy. Đúng không? Tất nhiên đây mình
cao là mình bằng 6. Tức là nó sẽ gì? Nó
sẽ có sáu cái f như thế sáu cái cộng lại
chia cho 6 ra lại cái điểm đây. Được
chưa?
Đúng không? Nếu không có cái R set này
các bạn không fix cái giá trị này mỗi
lần chạy ra một kết quả khác nhau. Tại
vì bên trong cái random F này có cái
boot shopping nó lấy mẫu. Mỗi lần nó lấy
mẫu là nó lại ra những tập con khác
nhau. Tập con khác nhau thì huấn luyện
mô hình nó cũng ra kết quả nó sẽ khác
nhau. Được chưa?
Thế các bạn cho hỏi này vẫn đang hỏi dở
là đây cái best score đang ở ở trên là
0,63 ở dưới là 0,61. Sao lại khác nhau
như thế?
Ở trên là 0,63, dưới lại ở trên 0,63,
dưới 0,61. Vì sao lại như thế?
sa
no no no no no no no sau khi các bạn fit
ở ở đây rồi ấy là nó sẽ giữ lại cái cái
cái bộ tham số cái bộ siêu tham số tốt
nhất tức là ở đây là nó dùng cái tốt
nhất nó không dùng mặc định đâu. Sau cái
dòng này là nó chỉ giữ cái tốt nhất
thôi. Đấy là cái đặc điểm của green
search. Các bạn fit xong là nó chỉ giữ
lại cái tốt nhất thôi.
Đây cũng là với bộ tốt nhất. Đây tốt
nhất sau. Ở trên này thì là 0,63. Dưới
còn có 0,61. Đây này.
Nhìn
vì sao? Ở trên in score này 0,63 ở dưới
là 0,61. Lý do là vì sao?
[khịt mũi]
Có ai giải thích được không? Vì sao ở
trên này là 0,63 xuống dưới chạy 0,61
đây này.
A cái ở trên không phải của không phải
cái cái ở trên là nó nó là cái tập va ẩn
ở trong bộ trên ấy đúng không? Ở đây này
nó là cái 0,63 này là ở trong cái bộ va
mà chúng ta dùng cái trong cái cây phâu
này ấy. Còn dưới là của bộ test. Dưới là
của bộ test. Hai bộ khác nhau đúng
không? bộ khác nhau. Kết quả trên bộ pha
tốt hơn kết quả trên bộ test.
Theo các bạn liệu có bao giờ có cái khả
năng là kết quả của bộ va không tốt bằng
của bộ test không? Đây trong trường hợp
này nhá là bộ va 0,63 đúng không? Bộ
test là 0,61. Có bao giờ có chuyện là bộ
test cái điểm nó tốt hơn điểm của bộ của
bộ va không? Các bạn
có khả năng đấy không? Có khả năng là
điểm bộ test tốt hơn điểm của bộ va
không?
Có khả năng nào điểm của bộ test tốt hơn
điểm của bộ không?
Ừ đúng có khả năng có thể bộ test nhiều
cô dễ đúng không?
Thông thường thì có thể là các bạn nghĩ
là đi thi học kỳ điểm sẽ cao hơn đi thi
tốt nghiệp ch phổ thông nhưng mà biết
đâu có ông lại đi thi học kỳ chỉ có 5 6
thi tốt nghiệp ch phổ thông lại gặp hôm
đề hợp lại được 9 10 làm sao không
chuyện bình thường đúng không?
Bộ va điểm có thể cao hơn người thấp hơn
một test chuyện bình thường đúng cái gì
cũng thể xảy ra đúng không? Thế thì các
bạn nhìn này. À còn một cái nữa các bạn
chú ý nhá. Ví dụ đây mình mình sẽ tăng
số độ tổ hợp lên tăng tộ tổ hợp ví dụ
đây nhá mình đây là mình đang thử này
thôi mình tăng nữa lên đúng không? 50
100 200 300
tăng nhiều lên tất nhiên là chạy nó thì
nó sẽ lâu thôi không chạy nó sẽ lâu thôi
đấy từ mình cho cái
mình cho cái số cái vâ này tăng lên in
nó nhiều nhìn nó nhiều nhá
chạy này thôi bình thường nếu các bạn để
này chạy nó như này thôi nó chạy như này
đây mình cho bạn tí nhá
các bạn nhìn nhá
Đây này cái cơ sổ mến chạy đây này. Được
chưa? Mình đang chạy đây này.
Của miếng chạy này đúng không? Nó như
thế này. Đấy nếu mà các bạn chạy chỉ như
này thôi. Đấy nó chạy nó cũng tương đối
lâu đúng không? Đấy xong ra cái đả này
chạy xong thì nó nó hết thôi. Xong thì
nó hết thôi. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ ấy
đây là nó là nó đang chạy đơn luồng.
Chạy đơn luồng tức là nó chỉ có một cái
luồng chính nó chạy thôi và không không
có cái gì khác nữa. Nhưng mà các bạn
biết biết là máy của chúng ta nó có nó
có rất là nhiều nhân, nó có rất nhiều
co. Mỗi một cái nhân nó chạy rất là
nhiều luồng đúng không? Bây giờ các bạn
muốn tận dụng cái sức mạnh của máy của
các bạn thì các bạn sẽ cho nó chạy đa
luồng. Chạy đa luồng thì làm thế nào các
bạn nhìn đây? Chạy đa luồng nhá. Trong
này các bạn cái green search này nó có
một cái tham số nó có một cái tham số nó
tên là jobs. Muốn chạy bao nhiêu luồng
chế song song này mặc định là một thôi.
Mặc định là bằng 1 các bạn có thể tăng
cái shop lên mình tăng lên là bằng mình
cho bằng bằng 6 nhá. Bằng 6 này
bằng 6 nhá. Các bạn nhìn nhìn thấy sự
khác biệt này nhá. Đầu tiên là mình sẽ
mở cửa sổ này nhá.
Đây nhá. Nhìn nhá. Xem bằng 6 nó khác
nào nhá. Vừa nãy bằng 1 này. Bằng 1 như
này. 1 nhìn nhá.
1 nhá. Nhìn này.
Đâu rồi?
Ơ nó bay đâu ấ nhỉ?
Bạn chờ tí chờ tí.
Đây xem bây giờ nó mới hiện ra này.
Ơ
các bạn chẽ thấy mình mở lại nhá.
Đây một là như này được chưa? Đ như này
được chưa? Nếu mà các bạn chỉ một luồng
này thôi nó chạy rất là chậm đúng không?
Tăng nhá. Tăng làm 6 này. 6 này. Chạy
thử này.
Các bạn nhìn này. 6 này. Thấy chưa? Khác
biệt chưa? Chạy đa luồng chưa? Muốn
nhanh nữa nhá. Các bạn muốn chạy maximum
có thể nhá. Cho -1 vào. -1 vào.
-1 nó chạy nhanh nhanh nữa. Đây các bạn.
Sao nó bị biến mất nhỉ?
Đây mình chẽ lại cho các bạn xem nhá.
Đây
đây bạn nhìn -1 này. Được chưa? Maximum
số luồng đây này. Được chưa? CB 100%
được chưa?
Được chưa?
Đấy thì các bạn bình thường ngày xưa ấy
nhưng mà các bạn dùng -1 ý thì lúc mà
các bạn đang dùng máy nó sẽ hơi bị lag
tại vì là nó dồn tài nguyên để nó chạy
cái này. Các bạn thấy vừa siv 100%
không? Nên thông thường ấy cô ngày xưa
lúc mình lúc mình còn đang ngồi làm
chiếc máy thì mình chỉ để Njob này mình
mình để job này bằng khoảng 2 với 4 thôi
6 là cùng. Còn lúc ví dụ mình chạy để
chạy qua đêm hôm sau đến test thì mình
cho nó chạy -1. Tức là trước khi mình đi
làm về mình cho nó -1 chạy qua đêm. Bắt
buộc phải test với nhiều tổ hợp N khác
nhau.
Bắt buộc phải test với nhiều tổ hợp khác
nhau. Làm thế nào để biết được cái nào
là tốt nhất? Tất nhiên phải test. Nhưng
nếu thế
nó là số chủ động mình nhập vào để test.
Tức là câu hỏi là gì nhỉ? Mình vẫn chưa
hiểu lắm. Bắt buộc phải test với nhiều
tổ hợp Nu. Hả thầy?
Các bạn không test cũng được.
Không test thì các bạn chỉ dùng không
test thì các bạn dùng mặc định thôi.
Không test dùng mặc định thôi đúng
không? Nếu nếu không muốn test thì tôi
dùng mặc định thôi. Coi như là nó cho
100 cây tôi dùng 100 cây. Nó cho dùng
gini tôi dùng gini thôi. Các bạn có thể
dùng cái mô hình nó có thể là mô hình
tốt nhất và có thể không phải tốt nhất
đúng không? Nếu các bạn không muốn test
nhiều thế này thì test này nó nhanh mà
nó có lâu đâu đúng không? Test này chạy
có mỗi mấy giây thôi mà đúng không? Mấy
chục giây thôi đúng không? Nó có lâu đâu
mà ngại đúng không?
Đúng không? Xong này các bạn học về deep
learning nó mới lâu. Machine nhanh lắm
các bạn. Âm chạy nãy giờ nó chưa đến 1
phút mà 1 phút thì có cái gì đâu mà tiếc
đúng không?
Có cách nào để tìm được điểm rơi đ thố
hữu? Đây cách đây cách đây
có cái chế độ nào để tìm ra tự động
trong cái trường hợp của random fed thì
nó là số cây nhá. Còn chắc cái mô hình
khác không phải mô hình nào nó nó cũng
có số cây đâu. Cái này chỉ có các bạn
thử nhiều, các bạn thử càng nhiều giải
giá trị thì các bạn sẽ có khả năng cao
các bạn tìm cái cái tổ hợp nó tốt hơn
thôi chứ còn nó cũng không có sẵn đâu.
Tại vì nếu mà nó có sẵn rồi thì chúng ta
còn có cái gì phải làm nữa đúng không?
Nếu mà sẵn hết rồi thì chúng ta thì máy
nó làm hết rồi đúng không? Chứ chỉ có
các bạn thử các bạn thử nó càng nhiều
giá trị thì các bạn sẽ càng gần với cái
giá trị tối ưu hơn đúng không? Cũng có
thể cũng có thể số lượng cây tối ưu nó
là một cái nó là một một cái số nó lẻ
hơi là lẻ nó là 78 chẳng hạn. Thì tất
nhiên là chúng ta sẽ chả quai chúng ta
trong đầu chúng ta nghĩ là thử một cái
số như vậy cả. Nhưng mà các bạn thử càng
nhiều số cái giải giá trị nó càng dày
lên thì sẽ càng khả năng cao các bạn sẽ
gần được cái giá trị tốt nhất này đúng
không? Cho chúng ta tìm hiểu tối yêu
chúng ta cũng không nhất thiết là phải
tìm được cái tổ hợp the best ever. Các
bạn chỉ được một cái tổ hợp nó tương đối
tốt thôi là cũng đã ok rồi đúng không?
Nếu tài nguyên local không đủ thì có cái
năng của tài nguyên nào để dụng. Với
machining thì khó có chuyện máy các bạn
không đủ tài nguyên lắm. Với deep
learning nó cần GPU thì mấy chứ còn với
machine nó chỉ chạy CPU thôi. Bây giờ
máy chúng ta bây giờ máy các bạn cổ lắm
phải co i5. Core i5 chạy cái này thoải
mái. Cái máy này co i3 là cái đời ngày
xưa ờ cái cái cái thường ngày xưa Intel
4 các thứ nó nó còn chạy được mà cái mấy
cái này chạy machining thoải mái các
bạn. Máy mà chạy chạy ngày xưa cái thời
của mình ngày xưa các bạn nào cùng người
lớn mình ngày xưa mình còn chúng ta các
bạn nhớ là có cái đời mà có cái gọi là
gọi là Pum 3 Petium 4 không. Đấy mấy cái
máy mấy cái máy P 4 nó còn chạy được cái
này cơ mà đúng bạn bạn nào mà cái lứa
cuối 8x đầu 9x mình ngày xưa nó có cái
máy cổ hay cái máy thùng to ấy đúng
không hồi đấy ngày xưa nó còn chị làm gì
đã có co I này I kia đúng không nó có
mấy cái máy Petium ấy Petium 4 chạy chậm
ơi là chậm chạy Windows XP ấy nó cũng
chạy được cái này cơ mà
nó không có đâu nó không có đâu nó chỉ
là đây là giá trị này làòn chúng ta
chúng ta cho vào chúng ta cho vào thôi
chứ còn nó không có một cái bộ tổ hợp nó
có có sẵn đâu không có tộ tộc có sẵn
đâu. Đấy. Tại vì
có sẵn rồi thì còn cái gì mà làm nữa
đúng không? Tất nhiên là AI rồi thư viện
nó làm sẵn nhưng mà cũng có những cái
chúng ta phải tự làm đúng không? Các bạn
test càng nhiều thì các bạn sẽ càng dễ
ra tổ hợp đấy thôi. Ví dụ nhá ví dụ nhỉ
lúc ban đầu ví dụ kinh nghiệm của mình
nhá. Lúc ban đầu các bạn sẽ test những
cái giá trị nó cách xa nhau. Ví dụ nhá
ví dụ ban đầu các bạn có thể test là 100
500 1000 được chưa? 1500 1000 nhá. Được
chưa? Thế bây giờ ấy giả sử cái tổ hợp
này mà nó ra cái 500 là cái tốt nhất thì
bây giờ các bạn sẽ chỉ search những cái
thứ loan canh 500 thôi. Còn nếu cái 100
tốt nhất các bạn se loan canh 100 thôi
hoặc là 1000 tốt nhất cái loanh 1000
thôi. Tức là gì? Tức là mình sẽ thu hẹp
dần cái phạm vi. Lần đầu phạm vi nó thật
là lớn đúng không? Mỗi lần sau tụi nhỏ
tụ nhỏ tụ nhỏ một tí đi. Đấy thì làm như
vậy các bạn sẽ dễ các bạn gọi là dễ tìm
được cái tổ hợp nó tốt hơn. Được chưa?
Còn tất nhiên lúc ban đầu các bạn sẽ
không biết là với cái bộ rượu này tôi
chỉ cần vài chục hay tôi cần vài trăm
hay tôi cần vài nghìn chúng ta sẽ không
biết được. Chúng ta sẽ phải thử những
cái thổi nó xa xa này. Ví dụ 100 500
1000 5000 ví dụ như vậy. Được chưa? Tất
nhiên mình mình mà chạy nó sẽ khá là lâu
đấy. 1000 thì 1000 thử nhá. Thử nhá.
1000 cây là cũng khá là nặng đấy. Mình
cho 6 rồi mình sợ nhiều quá nó lag sừ
máy mất. Được chưa? Đấy ví dụ nhá. Đây
được chưa? Lần đầu mình cứ cho phổ phổ
nó rộng vào. Lần sau mình sẽ thu nhỏ cái
cái phổ đi. Được chưa?
Đấy m ong này mỗi lần chạy nó trong một
tí một tí này nó chạy nó nhanh
số lượng cây nhiều nó thử nó lâu hơn.
Đây này. [hắng giọng]
Đây này các bạn nhìn này. Đây này. Nhìn
thấy chưa các bạn? Nhìn này. 1000 mình
đã thấy 1000 là tốt nhất. Tức là gì? Tức
là khả năng cao là những cái số mấy trăm
mấy trăm nó sẽ không phải là optimal
đâu. Thì bây giờ mình sẽ thử nó đăng kê
1000 ví dụ là 800 1000 hoặc các bạn có
thể thử to nữa lên được chưa? Đấy đấy là
cách cách thử đấy. Lần đầu các bạn cho
một cái phổ rộng nó giống kiểu tìm đường
á. Các bạn nào ở Hà Nội nhá tìm một cái
nhà đầu tiên các bạn sẽ tìm ở quận đúng
không? Xem là quận Hai Bà Trưng hay là
quận Ba Đình hay là quận à quận quận à
quận Hoàn Kiếm đúng không? Các bạn vào
được, các bạn biết cái quận nào là là
tối ưu rồi các bạn vào quận đấy, các bạn
tìm thu nhỏ ở bên trong đấy trong quận
Hai Bà Trưng các bạn tìm khu Bách Khoa
hay là khu khu gì gì đấy. Đấy chang như
vậy này được chưa?
Có thể có thể số lượng cây nhiều số
lượng cây nhiều tức là mô hình phức tạp
hơn mô hình phức tạp hơn có nghĩa là có
khả năng bị ý ting. Có thể nhưng mà muốn
biết là có over fiting hay không ấy
chúng mà phải nhìn vào đây tức là gì?
Nếu mà cái nếu mà cái điểm ở trên nó rất
là tốt nhưng điểm ở dưới nó tồi thì nó
mới là ô fiting đây các bạn không đây
này. Trên là 64, đây là 65 vẫn ok mà
đúng không? Fitting tức là gì? Ờ học học
thì tốt nhưng mà đi làm bài kiểm tra
hoặc là đi thi thì tồi. Tức là gì? Kết
quả trên bộ trin tốt nhưng mà bộ va tồi
hoặc là bộ vé tồi hoặc là bộ test tồi
hoặc là cả hai tồi hoặc là gì? Bộ trên
tốt, bộ va tốt nhưng bộ test tồi đúng
không? Còn đây mình thấy là va vẫn tốt,
test vẫn tốt thì chưa có cái gì để thể
hiện nó là fitting cả đúng không?
B có B có đấy là một cái ờ
không không cần phải grap grap không cần
phải grap làm gì mà phải khó đến thế hả
trời ơi ông fiting giống như kiểu các
bạn thích mỗi cái đứa nó đi học ấy con
của các bạn ở nhà nó có bị ô fiting
không dễ lắm hàng ngày nó đi học mà nó
toàn 9 với 10 đi thi nó toàn 1 với hai
thì đấy là ô fiting mà cần gì phải cần
gì phải phải phải cần gì phức tạp thế
đúng không Nên các bạn nhìn nó dễ không
mà đúng không? Cần gì phải lằng nhằng
đây ông này mà điểm cao đúng không? Thi
thi cuối kỳ điểm cao
mà đi thi tôi kêu chủ phớm điểm thất thì
nó là ô fiting mà đúng không? Nhìn nhìn
nhìn là ra mà grap rủng gì phức tạp ra
đúng không?
Đúng không? Tất nhiên các bạn cũng thể
các bạn vẽ đường ra được nhưng mà làm gì
phức tạp thế đúng không? Muốn biết ông
nào học vẹt nhìn vào điểm thi là ra ngay
ấ mà đúng không? Và các bạn nhớ nhá,
trên cao, cái điểm của bộ va cao và cái
điểm của bộ test thấp thì lúc này nó mới
đủ cũng thành ô fiting. Thế còn tren cao
va cao không thì cũng chưa nói lên điều
gì đúng không? Tại vì là trên cao va cao
mà test vẫn cao thì nghĩa là học tốt
thôi đúng không? Có một cái điểm mà
những người người ta học mới học
machining rất hay bị lạm dụng về cái ô
fiting tức là gì? Tức là cứ nhìn thấy
cái điểm cao là sợ fitting đúng. Điểm
cao thường nó dễ dẫn đến fiting nhưng nó
không phải là điều kiện đủ. Nó là nó là
điều kiện cần nhưng không phải đủ. Điều
kiện đủ là gì? Tức là va cũng cao, test
cũng cao. Lỗi lúc đấy à xin lỗi ạ. Điểm
điểm tức là điểm va cái performance điểm
nó cao mà điểm bộ test nó thấp ấy thì
lúc này nó mới đủ điều kiện nó cấu thành
là fitting đúng không? Tức là gì? Học
thì tốt mà thi thì tốt. Được chưa?
Đấy,
nhắc lại là gì là với cái mô hình
machining ấy chạy nó rất là nhanh nên
các bạn có thể các bạn thử rất nhiều tổ
hợp mà đây mình bây gi mình chỉ thử hai
tham số nhá. Thôi mình thử tiếp này. Thử
tiếp này
nhá. Thử tiếp này đi nhá. Ví dụ đây các
bạn nhìn này. Cái max dep đi đúng không?
Mặt cái non gì mình cho thêm một vài cái
nữa nhá. Mình cũng chả biết là bao nhiêu
thì maximum là tối ưu đấy. Cho vào đây
max này. Đấy được chưa? Max này được
chưa? Thử nhá. Non này 2 này. 5 này 10.
Được chưa? Ví dụ như vậy đúng không? Thế
là các bạn thấy không? 33 x 4 33 là 94
là 36. 36 rồi 36 nhân với 6 là 100
216 đúng không? Nó sẽ có 216 fit đúng
không? Chạy lâu phết đấy đúng không?
Chạy lâu phết đấy.
Đây 216 này. Đấy được chưa?
Đấy lại thử. Tất nhiên là chạy các bạn
chờ nó sẽ hơi lâu một tí. Được chưa?
Đấy thời gian này các bạn nhìn thời gian
nhanh đúng không? Bạn nào các bạn học
đến khóa sau deing các bạn thấy trên
phải đến nhanh thì phải tiếng không thì
phải có khi vài ngày nó mới xong mà
machining rất là nhanh đúng không? Em
máy nó chạy chạy cứng chạy đến đâu rồi?
Đây
đây đúng không?
Sáu luồng sáu luồng đây. Sáu luồng đây
đúng chưa? Sáu luồng này đúng không? Si
87% rồi mình mà cho -1 thì nó sẽ dùng
maximum luôn. Ch
rồi có nào câu hỏi gì không?
Thôi t là gì đây này? 1000 cây đúng
không? Có thể ghi 1000 trên 1000 có còn
tốt nữa cơ cho chưa có thử đên đúng
không? Max dep là non này. Entropy này.
Được chưa?
Đấy cái này là tìm nó sẽ tối ưu theo
kiểu là vét cạn. Vest cạn tức là gì? Tức
là có bao nhiêu có bao nhiêu tổ hợp nó
thử hết. Cái cách này thì không phải lúc
nào cũng áp dụng được. Tại vì nếu mà các
bạn muốn thử nhiều tổ hợp quá thì cách
này nó sẽ chờ rất là lâu. Thì đến buổi
project sau chúng ta sẽ xem có một cái
option thay thế để tôi sao tôi sẽ thay
vì tôi vé cạn tôi chỉ tôi chỉ tìm trong
một cái tập con các cái tổ hợp thôi đúng
không? Ví dụ tôi có tổng cộng là
tôi có tổng cộng là
tôi có tổng cộng là ba 36 tổ hợp. Tôi
chỉ tìm ngẫu nhiên khoảng 10 tổ hợp thôi
xem là cái nào tốt nhất. Được chưa?
Rồi các bạn còn cái gì chúng ta có thể
thử nữa các bạn. Theo các bạn đây là
mình đang thử là trong random fred mình
xem thử xem là tối và đây các bạn chú ý
đây là random fred mô hình khác các bạn
có thể tìm tham số khác. Ví dụ đây mình
đây là ví dụ đây là logist
logistic re được chưa? Cái logic
relation này thì nó không có cái random
state đâu. Và cái logistic này nó sẽ có
cái bộ tham số nó khác. Đây này. Bộ tham
số nó khác đây. Nó có những cái đây. Mở
cho các bạn nhìn nó dễ nhá. Logistic này
nhá.
Đây nhá. Được chưa?
Cái này nó có bộ tam số nó khác tên nó
khác đúng không? Thông thường cái ông
nào quan trọng nó đẩy lên trên ít quan
trọng đẩy xuống dưới. Ở đây các bạn đổi
mô hình mà các bạn vẫn giữ nguyên tham
số thì chạy nó sẽ bị lỗi. Tại vì là
tại vì logistic logistic nó chả có cái
tham số nào tên này cả. Hạ thử này.
Đấy
đấy lỗi ngay đúng không? Nó chả ông nào
tên là C. Được chưa? Đấy.
Rồi có ai có câu hỏi gì không? Ở đoạn
này có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Nào bây giờ các bạn nghĩ xem còn cái gì
chúng ta có thể thử chúng ta tối ưu nữa
nào.
Còn cái gì chúng ta có thể thử nữa các
bạn?
Còn cái gì các bạn nghĩ là có thể thử
nữa nào?
Còn cái gì chúng ta có thể thử nữa nà?
Nếu mình thử ra một tổ hợp mà có độ
chính xác là cỡ 0,9+ thì nó là tốt hay
là xấu? Câu này mình đã từng nói rồi
đúng không nào? Các bạn một mô hình phân
loại mà có độ chính xác trên 90% thì đây
là mô hình tốt hay mô hình tồi? Chắc
chắn chúng ta đã từng học rồi. Chắc chắn
chúng ta đã từng học rồi. Nào các bạn,
cả lớp. Mô hình có aquasi trên 0,9 thì
đây là mô hình tốt hay là mô hình tồi?
Kiểm tra bài cũ đấy.
Đúng rồi. Chưa đủ điều kiện để đánh giá.
Nó chưa chắc là tốt. Nó cũng chưa chắc
là tồi mà nó chưa đủ điều kiện đánh giá.
Vì sao lại chưa đủ điều kiện đánh giá hả
các bạn? Vì sao mà một cái mô hình biết
Aquacasi trên 10% các bạn lại không đủ
dữ kiện để các bạn đánh giá nó tốt hay
tối các bạn? Vì sao?
>> Thiếu thông tin của nghiệp vụ đấy.
>> Thông tin cụ thể là thông tin gì nhỉ?
>> Là của chuyên gia họ phải đánh giá xem
là cái mô hình đấy thì nó ưu tiên như
kiểu là ừ mô hình nó tỉ lệ bao nhiêu thì
mới là thực tế bao nhiêu thì mới là to
đạt tiêu chuẩn.
Ừ cũng có ý đúng nhưng mà có một cái ý
khác nó tổng quát hơn là vì cả lớp là vì
sao vì sao một cái mô hình Aquac trên
90% mình lại chưa đủ thông tin để mình
đánh giá là nó tốt hay nó hay tôi. Vì
sao thiếu thông tin gì?
Thiếu thông tin gì?
Ừ đúng rồi. Đúng rồi. Có biết nó cân
bằng hay không đâu đúng không? Nhưng nó
lệch làm sao đúng không? Bây giờ cái bây
giờ cái mô hình dự đoán người bị ung thư
đi đúng không? Bây giờ một cứ 100 người
đến 10 người ung thư cái mô hình của
bạn, mô hình của bạn ai người ta cũng
bảo là khỏe cả. Thế mô hình bây giờ dự
đoán đúng một kiểu đúng ai người ta nó
bảo là khỏe nó cũng được 90% đúng không?
Đâu có được ý nghĩa gì đâu đúng không?
Phải xem rượu nó có mất cân bằng hay
không đúng không? Accasi người ta chỉ
dùng khi mà dữ liệu cân bằng thôi. Còn
dữ liệu không mất cân bằng thì chả người
ta dùng accuraci cả đúng không? Đấy
đúng không? Làm sao mà dựa vào mỗi ac
trên 90% mà biết là mô hình tốt thì
không được đúng không? thiếu dữ liệu
được chưa này nó học rồi mà cái hôm
chúng ta học về các cái magic aquac one
mình hỏi các bạn chán ra rồi còn gì nữa
đúng không hôm nấy mình hỏi các bạn một
câu y mình bảo các bạn là bây giờ mình
mình mình chuyên được một cái mô hình
cho bên Vinmake họ để họ dự đoán xem là
mọi người người ta có bị bệnh hay không
mô hình của mình mà đợt Aquac 95% chẳng
hạn thì có tốt hay không đúng các bạn
trả lời chán rồi còn gì nữa đúng không
rồi thế đúng khôngên học lý thuyết là
phải ôn lại đúng không thì lúc thực hành
chúng ta sẽ có đủ kiến thức được chưa
rồi Rồi các bạn nào quay lại câu hỏi của
mình. Theo các bạn bây giờ có cái gì
chúng ta có thể thử nào? Chúng ta thử
đây là chúng ta thử green search với
runfet rồi chúng ta có thể chúng ta thử
với một vài mô hình khác nữa đúng không?
Theo các bạn có cái gì chúng ta có thể
thử nữa nào các bạn.
Các bạn nhìn này, như mình nói hôm qua
ấy, cái bộ rượu này theo lý thuyết về
mặt lý thuyết thì với cái bộ rượu này
khi mà chúng ta chẳng có cái feature nào
có cái hệ số tương quan lớn về cả tit cả
thì đáng nhẽ theo lý thuyết là những cái
mô hình phi tuyến giống như kiểu rom
fred ấy nó sẽ tốt hơn mô hình tuyến
tính. Thế nhưng mà hôm qua lúc mình thử
thì mình thấy là mô hình tuyến tính nó
còn tốt hơn. Chả biết vì sao đúng không?
Đấy là cái sự khác biệt giữa lý thuyết
với thực hành đúng không? Tức là gì?
Chúng ta không thể nào chúng ta chỉ dựa
vào lý thuyết được. Tức là gì? không thể
nào dựa vào cái việc là à với cái bộ
rượu này tôi nên dùng mô hình phi tuyến
là tôi chỉ dù thử phi tuyến tôi không
thử tuyển tính không phải như vậy đúng
không tôi phải thử hết đúng không
[hắng giọng] đấy là đặc quyền của các
cái mô hình machining khi mà cái thời
gian huấn luyện nó rất là nhanh
thế bây giờ ở trong trong machining bây
giờ các bạn có vài chục mô hình đúng
không thì về mặt kỹ thuật là đáng nhẽ
các bạn phải test thử thứng mô hình một
đúng không gì các bạn thử đ forest xong
các bạn ghi lại kết quả các bạn thử
logistic version xong ghi lại kết quả
các bạn thử từng mô hình ghi lại kết quả
như vậy đúng không nhưng mà thử từng mô
hình vậy rồi ghi lại như vậy Thì nó sẽ
làm sao hả các bạn? Thử từng mô hình rồi
kiện kết quả thì nó sẽ làm sao?
Thử từng mô hình với hiện kết quả thì
nói làm sao?
Ừ nó sẽ lâu đúng không? Lâu mất thời
gian đúng không? Rất là may cho các bạn
chứ không không may cho mình. Tại vì
thời ngày xưa của mình thì là mình bắt
buộc mình phải làm như thế chả có cách
nào khác. Bây giờ người ta đã có rất
nhiều thư viện người ta hỗ trợ các bạn
rồi. Trong đó thì có m vài cái thư viện
nó giúp các bạn chạy nó chạy giúp các
bạn chạy khoảng vài chục mô hình của một
lúc rất là nhanh. Các bạn chỉ đúng một
dòng thôi. Enter phát là nó chạy cho bạn
vài chục mô hình xong nó sắp xếp sẵn cho
các bạn luôn. Được chưa?
Thế thì mình sẽ chị bạn một cái thư viện
như vậy. Có một cái thư viện các bạn
nhìn cái tên các bạn sẽ biết ngay là nó
dùng để làm gì. Nó là lazy predict.
Lazy là lười đúng không? Lazy predict.
Cái thư viện này cài rất là dễ. Đây cài
đúng một dòng này thôi. Pip cách install
cách lazy predict để mình copy cho các
bạn nhá. Được chưa? Các bạn mở cái
terminal ra. Mở terminal ra như này.
Được chưa? Mình thì mình có rồi. Mình
cài lại cùng với các bạn thôi chứ mình
có rồi này.
Đây nhá. Có rồi này. Pip cách install
cách lazy predict nhá. Đúng không? Enter
một cái này.
Đấy mình có rồi nên là nó nên là nó cũng
chả làm cái gì mới cả. Được chưa? Cách
dùng cực kỳ dễ luôn. Các bạn nhìn này.
Dùng nhá. Ví dụ nó sẽ có hai bài toán là
classification với request. Thì các bạn
nhìn classification này. Được chưa? Dùng
dễ lắm. Đây các bạn nhìn nó sẽ y trong
một cái bảng như này. Đấy sắp xếp mình
không nhớ sắp xếp theo cái gì. Hình như
nó sắp xếp theo cái ROC AOU thì phải.
Tức là nhá các bạn dùng rất là dễ thôi
nhá. Bây giờ các bạn sẽ có một cái dòng
import này. Đây form lazy predict nhá.
Đây này.
Đây cái dòng như này nhá. Được chưa? Ở
dưới mình sẽ có thêm một cái dòng như
này đây này. Đây. Đấy. Xong cái dòng này
xong này. Models models của S này. Bây
giờ mình sẽ không dùng green search nữa
được chưa? Mình không dùng green search
nữa. Mình tắt hết chỗ này đi.
Mình nhét luôn cái nhét nh tắt cả đây
luôn này
nhá. Mình sẽ để luôn vào đây.
Quên chưa khởi tạo đây một dòng này nữa
này.
Được chưa? X thường này. X này. Sau cái
dòng này ấ các bạn mở cái models này ra
xem cũng được. Các bạn mở cái prediction
này ra cũng được. Hai cái mở cái nào
cũng được nhá. Mình chạy thử các bạn xem
nhá. Chạy thử này. Tất nhiên nếu mình
chạy chạy ở đây thôi ấy thì nó nó không
show ra cái gì cả. Đây các bạn nhìn mình
chạy thử này. Nó không show tại vì mình
có in ra cái gì đâu đúng không các bạn?
Nhìn nhá. Chờ một tí này. Nó lại có một
vài cái dòng message ở đây nó sẽ chạy.
Nó sẽ chạy tức là gì? Về mặt bản chất là
nó sẽ thử vài chục cái mô hình như này
nó sắp xếp nó có mấy cột là Aquac này.
Balan Aquacasi. Cái này các bạn không
quan tâm lắm. Chỉ quan tâm Aquacasi này.
R AOC F1 này. Và cái thời gian chạy.
Thời gian chạy thì đây chạy mất bao
nhiêu giây? Nếu mình nhớ không nhầm là
nó sắp theo cái tí mình vào cái mã nguồn
mình xem hình như nó sắp xếp theo cái
AUC thì phải nhá.
Chạy lần đầu nó sẽ hơi lâu các bạn nhá.
Lần đầu chạy nó sẽ hơi lâu một tí. Lần
sau từ lần hai chạy nó sẽ nhanh nhanh
nhanh hơn. Được chưa? Để mình vào đây
xem nó sẽ hết đầu cái gì.
Đây là mình đi vào mã nguồn các bạn nhá.
Đi vào mã nguồn thì các bạn giữ control
các bạn click vào cái tên này nó đi vào
mã nguồn này nó sẽ theo đây này. Nó đang
chạy này. Nó chạy 32 mô hình khác nhau.
Nó sẽ theo cái gì ấ nhở? Sort đi
à. Đây nó sắp xếp theo balance accuracy
giảm dần.
Tiếp theo balance acuracy. Balance aquac
khác gì nhỉ?
Balance ac này
khác gì nhở? Balance
à? Ok. Ok. B rồi. Ok. Trung bình
tức là nó là trung bình không trọng số
đấy.
Trung bình không trọng số của rec nàyy
này. Đúng không? Nó là trung bình của
recol.
Trung bình không trọng số. Ok rồi không
sao. Ok các bạn nh chạy xong nhưng mà nó
cũng chả in ra cái gì thì mình có in cái
gì đâu đúng không? Bây giờ mình muốn in
thì mình phải in một th này ra đúng
không? Mình chạy gọi lại bô đen nhá.
Đúng không? Mình lại cách cũ này. Bô đen
hết ra được chưa? Sau click chuột phải
này lại chọn execute selection console
này. Được chưa? Bạn nào các bạn dùng pay
như mình các bạn dùng này không thì các
bạn cứ in thẳng cái model này ra cũng
được. Một trong hai ông in ông nào cũng
được. Được chưa? B đen nhá. Click chuột
file này. Chọn này. Execute selection
console nhá. Nhìn này.
Vẫn theo được đúng không các bạn? Có
nhanh quá không?
Nhanh quá bảo mình nhá. Mình giảm tốc độ
chậm đi nhá. Được chưa?
Các bạn chờ một tí nó góc dưới bên phải
đây nó bắt đầu nó hiện ra nhá. Các bạn
mở ông nào cũng được. Mở models cũng
được. Mở preditions cũng ok nhá các bạn
nhìn này. Đây đấy chưa nó sắp thự giảm
dần của balance bence là có nghĩa gì tức
là nó là trung bình cộng của các cái
recol các bạn có hai class thì nó cộng
trung bình cộng lại chia đôi được chưa
càng ông trên thì càng tốt càng ông dưới
thì càng tồi. Được chưa? Cái thời gian
này gian này được chưa? Đấy các bạn đây
là các bạn khoảng ba mươi mấy mô hình
này thô bình thường các bạn thường ngày
xưa mình nó chưa có cái thư viện này nhá
là phải ngồi gõ xem s có nh cái mô hình
gì dành cho bài toán phân loại sau đó gõ
từng mô hình một rất là lâu. Hôm nay các
bạn dùng thư viện cổ phát xong được
chưa?
Tất nhiên với những cái mô hình
machining cơ bản này thì ra cái phần
thời gian nó không không quan trọng lắm
tại vì thường cái mô hình này nó rất là
nhanh cá biệt của cái ông này là 3 giây
mới xong còn đâu nhưng ông kia toàn
ba mươi mấy mzây là xong rồi đúng không?
0,36 mây đã xong rất là nhanh đúng
không? Cái thời gian với các cái mô hình
machine này có có thể nó chưa phải vấn
đề lắm.
Ừ nó chạy toàn mặc định cả. Chính xác nó
chạy toàn toàn mặc định cả.
Tất cả nó dù tham số mặc định. Thế nên
cách người ta dùng là gì? Thông thường
ấy mẹo các bạn dùng là gì? Là lúc đầu
các bạn sẽ chạy cái lazy break này. Các
bạn sẽ lấy top 5 top 10 những cái mô
hình tốt nhất với tham số mặc định. Sau
đó các bạn dùng green search với từng
ông một để xem là xem là tối ưu của từng
ông ông nào ông nào tốt. Được chưa? Đấy,
đầu tiên là dùng cái này để lấy nhanh
top 5 top 10. Sau đó với từng cái mô
hình đấy các bạn green search để các bạn
tìm ra cái bộ xấu tốt nhất rồi x lại
soánh lại một lần nữa. Tại vì có khả
năng là với tham số mặc định mô hình A
tốt hơn mô hình B nhưng mà với tham số
được tối ưu thì mô hình B lại tốt hơn. Đ
thôi
rồi.
Có ai có câu hỏi gì không? Đấy thường
ngày xưa hồi mình là còn làm data s nó
không có thư viện này đâu. Có phải ngồi
có phải ngồi gõ thủ công
chưa? Có ai có thắc mắc gì không? Tiện
không bạn? Một phát là xong.
Các bạn đừng lo cái việc là các bạn
không biết hết các cái thuật toán này.
Mình cũng chỉ biết khoảng 2/3 chỗ này
thôi. Cũng khoảng 1/3 1/4 1/3 là mình
không biết nó là cái gì nhưng mà cũng
chả vấn đề gì cả. Yêu cùng khi mà các
bạn đi làm thì quan trọng là cái mô hình
nó dự đoán tốt nó đưa ra cái bản nó
[hắng giọng] là cái thứ mà nó hữu ích
với mình thôi. Còn cái việc các bạn biết
cụ thể là cái gì cũng không quan trọng
mà. Thật ra khi mà các bạn thấy ví dụ
các bạn thấy cái mô hình này nó tốt nhất
đúng không? Các bạn dùng nó rồi các bạn
có thể các bạn bắt đầu các bạn tìm tài
liệu đọc về nó không có vấn đề gì cả.
Cái việc mà cái lúc các bạn chạy này các
bạn không biết tên cái mô hình nói
chuyện hoàn là bình thường nhá.
Rồi
thôi đây cách đây các bạn tối ưu đúng
không? Dùng lazy PR để chạy một lần thô
trước sau các bạn dùng Win để các bạn
fool cho từng ông một được chưa?
Dùng lazy trước tiền sử sau.
Dùng lazy trước thì còn tiền sửu vào đâu
nữa đúng không?
Lazy là cái bước cuối cùng rồi. Đây là
cái bước các bạn chạy mô hình rồi. Chạy
mô hình xong rồi thì còn tiền xử lý để
làm gì nữa đúng không? Đi thi xong rồi
thì học làm cái gì nữa đúng không? Đây
là đi thi rồi đi thi rồi thì thi xong
thì học làm cái gì nữa đúng không?
Đúng rồi. Bước này nó chỉ tin cậy khi mà
các bước trước nó cũng xử lý đúng thôi.
Đúng không?
Đây là bước đi thi học kỳ này. Nếu không
thi học kỳ này muốn xử lý giờ phải xử lý
trước đúng không?
Đấy thế thôi các nghĩ ra cái prediction
nó y hệt thế mà hai ông in cái nào cũng
được nhá.
Buổi sau chúng ta học về mô hình request
nó cũng y chang này. Nó cũng có một cái
bảng y trang đây. Regession nó cũng thế
đâ. Đây là classification regression nó
cũng cái bảng y trang như thế đây. Đấy
được chưa? Reation còn nhiều mô hình
hơn.
Là mình lazy xong mình sẽ chọn ra mô
hình có số điểm của matric mình chọn để
đánh giá thích nhất.
Tức là như thế này nhá. Tức mọi người
như thế này nhá. Mình nói nói lại như
này nhá. Tức là làm tức là cái quy trình
là gì? Đầu tiên chúng ta sẽ dùng lazy
predict để chúng ta test nhanh xem là
với ba mươi mấy bốn mấy mô hình này với
cái bộ tham số màng định ấy thì mô hình
nào nó là thì mình lấy top 5 hoặc top 10
những cái mô hình tốt nhất với cái bộ
xem số mạng định. Sau đó rồi mình sẽ với
từng cái mô hình này các bạn sẽ bắt đầu
các bạn dùng green search
để các bạn kiểm tra xem một lần là bây
giờ tôi dùng cái bộ tôi muốn tìm ra cái
bộ xâ số nó tối ưu sau các bạn lại xoánh
một lần nữa là cái bộ tối ưu của cái ông
top 10 đấy sẽ là ông nào tốt nhất lần
cuối thì các bạn lấy ra được chưa đấy là
cái quy trình được chưa
dùng lazy ý mình là dùng lazy trước
scare hay là sau nhưng mà làm sao mà có
thể dùng lazy
trước scare nhỉ
Ý là dùng cái ly này trước scaler đúng
không? Làm sao làm sao mà để cái
scalarer ra sau nhỉ? L xong là hết phim
rồi.
Ly xong là hết phim rồi. Còn cái gì ở
đâu nhỉ? Dùng sau thì dùng sau kiểu gì?
Bây giờ bạn mọ đẩy cái này ra sau á? Sau
bằng cách nào bây giờ? Mình vẫn chưa
hiểu. Đây là đi thi học kỳ rồi. Thi học
kỳ xong rồi thì
thi xong rồi thì thi học làm cái gì nữa
đúng không? Đây là đi thi rồi. Thi xong
là điểm yếc xong hết rồi thì thì còn học
hành cái cái nỗi gì nữa đúng không?
Đúng không? Làm sao đẩy scalar ra sau
được? Mình vẫn chưa hình dung được. Làm
sao đẩy ra sau được? Làm sao có thể làm
được?
>> À alo mình tại mình tại mình ghi nhầm á.
Ý là mình hỏi mình dùng ly á mình không
cần dùng scalar luôn được. Ý là cái dòng
la nó phía trên luôn á.
Cái này theo mình hiểu là phải xử lý dữ
liệu trước đúng không?
>> Vâng đúng rồi.
>> Mình mới lazy đúng không?
>> Đúng rồi. Còn cái thí dụ mình không
không mình bỏ quước tiền xử lý dữ liệu
mình lazy luôn á thì cái nào nó sẽ tốt
hơn?
>> Th mình phải thử hai cái. Thật ra nhá
trong cái lazy classifier này ấ bên
trong nó cũng có cái phép tiền nó người
ta cũng quy ước cái bước tiền xử lý cho
các cái dữ liệu khác nhau rồi. Tức là kể
cả chúng ta không tiền xử lý thì ở trong
nó cũng xử lý. Thế nhưng mà nếu chúng ta
muốn là chúng ta muốn xử lý theo cái
cách của mình thì đây đúng không? Tức là
gì? Một là các bạn kiểu các bạn dùng
dịch vụ các bạn cho người ta làm mọi thứ
còn không là đây tôi chỉ tôi làm cái
bước tôi làm lông các thứ tôi làm ở đây
sau đó tôi chỉ dùng ông để ông chạy
nhiều mình cùng một lúc thôi. Đúng cái
nào cũng được các bạn mình cũng không
thể mình cho các bạn kết quả là cái nào
nó rút loạn tốt hơn. Tại vì có thể có
trường hợp các bạn xử lý theo cách của
bạn nó sẽ tốt hơn. Có cái trường hợp là
đưa vào trong đây nó dùng cái xử lý của
nó nó tốt hơn. Thế nhưng mà nhìn chung
chúng ta sẽ thử thử cả hai cách. Thử cả
hai cách đúng không? Trong machin lý
thuyết nó chỉ là lý thuyết lúc nào chúng
ta cũng phải thử đúng không? Không tin
bố con thằng nào được. Kể cả mình có nói
các bạn vẫn xét các bạn phải thử thử tự
thử lại. Tại vì có thể cái lý thuyết này
nó đúng trong cái trường hợp này nhưng
nó sẽ không đúng với cái trường hợp
khác. Thế nên với các bạn là cách thứ
nhất là gì? Là thử đúng không? Tại vì
sao? Trong lúc chúng ta ngồi chúng ta
chúng ta lập luận ý là khi chúng ta thử
nó xong xử rồi. Mà các bạn nhớ là nhớ
nhá. Đặc quyền của machining là gì? Là
rất dễ thử.
Khi nào các bạn học đến cái khóa sau
cơning không thể thử nổi tại vì sao? là
một cái lần chêning là hết hàng giờ rồi
nhá.
Rồi ok thấy chưa? Đấy cái này ngày xưa
hồi cái hồi ngày xưa mình làm là không
có cái thư viện này. Ngày xưa mình làm
là phải ngồi làm một cái list tên từng
cái mô hình một. Sau đó bắt đầu cứ một
cái vòng là for loop qua từng ông một
xong bắt đầu fit ph fit fit mấy chục cái
fit xong bắt đầu up ra kết quả xong up
vào một cái list nữa. Rồi xánh sót cái
list đấy rất là mất thời gian. Bây giờ
thì nó dễ rồi nha.
Đấy đúng không các bạn? Không có xử lý
nó nó vẫn chạy mình cũng không biết là
chạy xong thì cái nào nó tốt hơn mình
phải thử thôi
nhá. Được chưa
các bạn không? Thật ra ấy thì
với truyền thống này ấ cũng thật ra nó
không có quá khó. Tại vì sao? Nhưng cái
khó nhất ấ thư viện nó làm hết rồi.
Chúng ta chỉ gọi ra thôi mà. Đúng không
các bạn không? Mình mà bỏ bớt m cái dòng
râu ri nhá thì k đoạn code này chắc chỉ
khoảng được 20 dòng thôi đúng không?
Chưa đến 20 dòng đúng không? So với cái
dâu diên nó chỉ dòng tại vì sao? Mọi thứ
thực viện nó làm hết rồi đúng không?
Tiền xỉ nó làm rồi, huấn luyện nó làm
rồi, tối ưu nó làm rồi, nó làm hết rồi.
Mình chỉ cần như mình gọi ra thôi. Rất
là dễ.
Thế thôi. Có ch nào các mô hình người
maybe có trường hợp nào các cái mô hình
top dưới của Lazy nó có tất nhiên. Tất
nhiên cái cái điều mà em nói
là có thể đúng không? Có thể là gì? Có
thể là cái mô hình mà lúc mặc định ý nó
nằm ngoài top 10 nhưng mà file tool rồi
nó lại vào trong top 2 top 3 cũng có
thể. Thế nhưng mà nếu chẳng may cái khả
đấy chắc chúng ta cũng phải chịu thôi.
Tại vì là chúng ta cũng không có sức
chúng ta thử từng mô hình một đúng
không? Ba mười mấy mô hình mà chúng ta
green search từng ông một nó lâu quá
đúng không? Thường ví dụ như mình mình
chỉ lấy top 5 thôi. Top 5 thôi. Tốt hay
không tôi cũng chịu đúng không? Top 5
thôi. Mình lấy cái giả sử gì? là với mặc
định cái những cái môi này nó là top 5
thì có lẽ là file tool thì có lẽ nó cũng
nằm trong top 5 đấy
nhá. Những cái mô hình machining chúng
ta học trong cái khóa này ấy sẽ đặc biệt
nó phù hợp với rượu dạng bảng. Rượu dạng
bảng thì nó cái mô hình m đặc biệt phù
hợp với những rượu phức tạp hơn như ví
dụ là văn bản hoặc là hình ảnh hoặc là
âm thanh chẳng hạn thì lúc này nó sẽ cần
những cái thứ khác được chưa? Thế nhưng
mà với maching truyền thống thì diệu dạ
bảng là vô cùng phù hợp.
Có bắt nào muốn hỏi gì không?
Rồi nghỉ ra 5 phút nhá. Không nghỉ ra 5
phút nhá.
Ừ mình xong bằng magic. Đúng rồi. Đúng
rồi. Chính xác xong bằng magic đấy. Đấy
đây chạy này. Đúng không? Mình xem là
cái model này đi. Đó
thế này xong máy trí thôi. Đó
như mình đơn giản mình lấy cái top 5
trên cùng đây các bạn chờ chạy lại này.
Đây đó đên này lấy top 5 này 1 2 3 4 5
này chưa nó sắp hết sẵn rồi. Nó sắp xếp
dự cái balance Aquac nhưng mà các bạn
muốn đổi thì cũng được. Đổi thì các bạn
à đổi thì các bạn vào mã nguồn đây. Mã
nguồn của nó đây này. Cái classify nhá
đúng không?
Ờ mặc định ấ là nó dùng cái này
mặc định ấ là nó sót bằng cái balance
ac. Nếu là mình mình muốn đổi thì mình
sẽ vào đây mình nhảy vào. Tất nhiên mình
mình không sửa mã nguồn đâu. Mình sẽ kế
thừa mình sẽ mình sẽ kế thừa từ cái
class này rồi mình sẽ mình sẽ đổi đi
đúng mình tôi muốn dùng F1 chẳng hạn thì
tôi mới đổi vào đây. Thế xong thì mình
lấy cái top top 5 này năm bóng trên
cùng. Thế thôi chưa?
Thôi đây các bạn thấy không? Mấy hôm này
đây 47 77 này 75 các thứ này đâu cái nó
càng giảm dần này được chưa?
Các bạn chú ý này, các bạn thử nhìn này.
Các bạn nhìn kỹ mà xem hai mô hình này
thật ra là performance nó là như nhau
đúng không? Hai mô hình thật ra mô hình
nó là như nhau
đúng không?
Bốn thật ra thật ra là bốn mô hình đầu
tiên thật ra là bốn mô hình đầu tiên các
bạn nhìn không? Kết quả như nhau chá gì
nhau cả bằng nhau đúng không? Coi như là
làm tròn lấy bốn chữ số lấy năm chữ số
song phần thập phân là bằng nhau đúng
không? bằng nhau đủ cả bốn cộ này. Theo
các bạn bây giờ nếu bây giờ bốn cái mô
hình này nó tôi thấy tốt ngay nhau như
vậy. Theo các bạn nếu các bạn là mình
các bạn sẽ chọn mô hình nào trong bốn mô
hình này? Nếu bây giờ bốn cái mô hình
đầu tiên này mọi thứ đều the same này.
Theo các bạn các bạn sẽ lấy mô hình nào?
Các bạn sẽ lấy mô hình nào?
Đây bốn ông đầu đây. Top 4 này. Chính
xác. Đúng rồi.
Ông nào đây? Ông này bé nhất này đúng
không?
kết quả bằng nhau thì ông nào làm đều
làm bài được 10 điểm cả thì ông nào làm
nhanh thì ông ông ấy là ông tốt đúng
không? Tính về thời gian được chưa?
Cái thời gian này nếu các bạn chỉ chạy
phục vụ cho một người thì có thể nó
không phải vấn đề nhưng mà các bạn chạy
phụ cho hàng nghìn người một lúc chạy
thời gian thực nó phải dự án liên tục
chẳng hạn thì cái thờ này là một cái rất
là quan trọng. Ví dụ này các bạn học về
bài toán ser forecasting dự đoán chuỗi
thời gian ấy có khi dự án sữa liên tục
từng giây một thì cái thời gian này nó
rất là quan trọng. Muốn chạy real time
thì tôi phải như nào đúng không?
Rồi ok nhá. Kỉnh giá 5 phút nhá. Giá 5
phút nhá. Được chưa?
muốn hỏi thì các bạn cứ hỏi nhá. Mình
vẫn ngồi trước máy thôi xem có gì hay
không.
Thật ra ấy ngày xưa trên trường mình ấy
lúc mà mình à
ngày xưa lúc mình đi học ấy thật ra cái
thật ra cái môn machining của mình ấy
tất cả những cái gì mình dạy các bạn từ
đầu khóa đến giờ môn machine này tức là
mình học ấy là mình chỉ học trong có nửa
buổi thôi tại vì maching nó ngày xưa tại
vì cái lúc mình học trên trường là
chuyên ngành của mình là nó đi show về
deep learning nhiều hơning là chú ớ là
mình lấy từ cái lúc mà quá trình đi làm
ấy đi làm phải dùng nó vỡ nhiều còn đi
học thì thì Nó ít lắm. Đi học ít lắm.
Chớ là học phải de bing là nhiều.
[hắng giọng]
Sau này các bạn sau này các bạn mà học
về deep learning ấ các bạn thấy là
machine rất là chán. Mìnhing rất là
chán. Thuật toán là thuật toán đơn giản.
Deep learning các bạn. Đấy là toàn những
thuật toán hàng triệu tham số, hàng chục
triệu tham số. Thậm chí là các mô hình
ngô ng lớn nó lấy hàng tỷ tham số. Trong
khi mấy cái mô hình này nó chỉ có khoảng
chục trăm thôi cũng như mô hình nó chỉ
vài chục tham số thôi. Thế nhưng mà đây
là cái nền nền tảng nếu các bạn học chắc
về machining ấ sau học diing rất là
sướng luôn.
Có h này mình sẽ có một project về NLP
và một project về computer vision. Thế
nhưng để giải quyết các tán trong bảng
NLP và computer vision ấy thông thường
người ta sẽ không dùng các cái thuật
toán machining mà chúng ta học trong
khóa này. Vì sao đến đế buổi thự hành
địa chỉ các bạn? Tức là gì? Về mặt kỹ
thuật thì một vài bài toán đơn giản
chúng ta vẫn có thể dùng các bán machine
truyền thống được. Ví dụ là Rom Forest
Ery
support V machine dùng thì vẫn được
nhưng trong thực tế người ta sẽ ít khi
người ta dùng các cái thu toán cổ điển
để người ta giải quyết nó. Tại vì sao?
Thì nó có những cái hạn chế những cái th
toán chúng ta học trong cái khóa này nó
sẽ phù hợp hơn với dượu dạng bảng. Nhưng
mà mình vẫn sẽ chỉ các bạn xem là nếu
tôi áp dụng NLP áp dụng Gion nó trông
như nào nhá. Vẫn có cái NLP nó sẽ làọ nó
sẽ là cái project thứ tư còn camion nó
là thứ năm.
Cái trưởng của mình thì nó là theo hướng
nghiên cứu nhưng mà mình đi theo hướng
đi làm tại vì mình sợ nghiên cứu. Nghiên
cứu nghiên cứu mệt lắm các bạn. Nghiên
cứu khó mệt lắm.
nghiên cứu mình nghĩ phải người thông
minh mà mình thì cũng làại tằng tằng
tằng thôi. Mình mình không nghiên cứu
thì không mình đi làm cho nó mát.
Nghiên cứu là phải tìm ra cái mới hoặc
là cải thiện. Tức là ra cái gì mới mới
chưa ai làm bao giờ hoặc là
mình chỉ thích là lắp ghép những cái thứ
cũ làm với nhau thôi. Ừ. Cái gì ấy nhỉ?
Sáng nay a
sáng nay trên trường mình mình có cái
gọi là open day mình được phân công làm
mấy cái game mấy cái game a dùng
mình được phân công làm mấy cái game
kiểu computer vision cho cho mấy thường
là học sinh cấp ba nó đến chơi tức là nó
đến để nó xem kiểu định định hướng đấy
Việt Nam mình cũng mới gọi là gì gọi là
định hướng đi đúng không đấy làm mấy cái
trò trò này cho cho cho các bé chơ
à ii nó cho b là ming
dự đo đáo giá nhà thì nó cần là gồm hợp
cái gì nữa? Cái model của mình là phần
back end. Model là back end. Mình còn
một cái phần front end nữa. Phend tí
mình chỉ các bạn cách ph mình chỉ bạn
coding dễ lắm nhá. Tí mình chỉ các bạn
cách vi coding cực kỳ dễ luôn.
[hắng giọng][ho]
Tí mình chỉ cho có giao tiếp người cần
cái ui
user interface đúng không? Giao diện
người dùng.
Tí mình chỉ cho dễ lắm.
Cái phần back end mới khó. Phần from thì
thì back end mới cần học. Còn front end
thì cứ đây tí mình chỉ các bạn mình dùng
tí mình dùng s mình làm cho bạn cái cái
front
Ừ.
Có có có có đây giờ ng phút mình chỉ các
bạn cách cái lưu đây có cả lưu xong sau
đó mình deploy nhá.
Chọn làm th về data là tốt nhất.
Thú thật là mình cũng không rõ lắm tại
vì là mình à mình cũng không mình cũng
không dùng nó là thú th tại vì tại vì
mình học từ ngày xưa rồi đúng không? Bây
giờ mình biết rồi nên là mình cũng không
hỏi nhưng mà nếu mà ờ
thấy bảo có vẻ gaming có vẻ là cái thứ
liên quan đến research có vẻ ok theo
mình thấy bảo như thế tại vì là mình
cũng không mình mình
bây giờ mình toàn dùng ai để code thôi
chứ còn dùng ai để để học học cái này
thì mình cũng không không khỏe lắm đề
tĩa mình mình mình thử search search
nhanh xem mình cũng không rõ lắm mình
thì hầu hết mình chỉ dùng chatt thôi với
cả close thôi. Cốt thì hay bị cháy toần
quá mà thắng nó hay dùng. Thắng em mình
nó hay dùng nên là toàn nhường nó. Mình
toàn mình toàn vi code bằng chatbt nó
không có tốt bằng close nhưng mà cũng
sải tạm được. Chứ còn
ể để học các thứ thì thôi là mình cũng
không mấy lắm để tí mình thử tham khảo
xem.
Tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá.
Rồi ok. Cái cái mà các bạn vừa hỏi này
các bạn nhìn này. Thì bây giờ ấy ờ ok
đây là chúng ta dùng lazy bck chúng ta
biết thế rồi đúng không? Mình sẽ tắt tạm
đi nhá. Tại vì là biết là như vậy thôi.
Thế các bạn nhìn này. Thế bây giờ nhá
ờ
bây giờ cứ giả sử là mình đã huấn luyện
xong rồi đi. Đây huấn luyện xong nhá.
Đây đây. Được chưa? Huấn luyện xong rồi
đi. Được chưa? Thế lại nhá.
Thế lại này. Được chưa?
Ui chạy nhiều quá. Từ từ từ từ. What the
second này nhá. Được chưa? Mình chạy
xong nhá. Đúng không? Thế nhưng mà các
bạn nhìn này. Bây giờ ấy mình muốn đem
mình đi dự đoán ấy đúng không? Bây giờ
mình muốn đem mình đi dự đoán ấy là mình
lại cứ phải nếu mình cứ chạy cái script
này nhá. Đúng không? Thì bây giờ muốn
muốn đem mình đi đi dự đoán thì lại cứ
phải chạy chêning lại đúng không? Chạy
thấy tốn thời gian lắm đúng không? Cứ
mỗi lần muốn dự đoán gì lại phải chêning
thì mất thời gian lắm đúng không? Thì
bây giờ sau khi mình fit xong này ấy
mình nên xếp cái mô hình này lại. Mình
nên xếp mô hình này lại để làm sao? Để
lần lần tới tôi chỉ lôi ra thôi. Được
chưa? Muốn xếp mô hình thế nào? Muốn xếp
mô hình rất là dễ. Các bạn có vài cách
cơ. Với Python thì một các bạn dùng thư
viện picker hai. Đây mình chỉ các bạn
nhá. Giả sử nhá không có mình ngồi hướng
dẫn các bạn các bạn chỉ Google thôi. Các
bạn cũng chả chvt đúng không? How to set
learn model kiểu gì nó chả có cái đoạn
ai nó trả ở đây trước đúng không? Nó có
hai cách. Đây job với picker này các bạn
thấy chưa?
Cái nào cũng được. Đây save thì đây,
load từ đây đúng không? Picker thì cũng
dễ luôn. Đây picker đây. Cách nào cũng
được. Mình thì trước mình hay dùng cách
trên mà thôi. Mình dừng cách dưới cũng
được. Đây picker. Picker là một cái thư
viện rất là hay trong Python. Nó giúp
các bạn xếp bất kể thứ gì. Các bạn muốn
xếp cái gì các bạn cũng dùng picker
được. Được chưa? Xếp nhá.
Này nhá. Chên xong một cái tôi xếp luôn.
Được chưa? Xếp luôn. Đây. Import ở trên
đi.
Xếp luôn nhá. Để tĩa mình lôi cho mình
mình dùng mà đúng không nhá. Mình có thể
có thể cho nó cái tên tên là model.pll
đuôi picker này [hắng giọng] model ở đây
đây là tôi xếp nó lại các bạn nhớ mình
chạy xong nó sẽ hiện ra một cái file tên
là model.pkl ở đây nhá. Nhìn này nhìn
này.
Tất nhiên nó lại xếp cái môn hình tốt
nhất rồi. Moder fit xong nó sẽ màn hình
tốt nhất. Được chưa?
Chờ một tí nhá. Chờ tí xếp xong mình cho
các bạn xem nhá.
Đúng rồi các bạn nhìn này. Đây này. Đây
này. Model.pk đây này. Được chưa? Nó
chắc là nặng. Mình nghĩ là có phải nặng
khoảng à đây là mô hình gì? Đây là
random forest đúng không? Random forest
mà 1000 cây thì chắc là cũng phải nặng
chắc là phải vài mê đấy. Có khi vài có
khi vài chục mê đấy. Xem nào. Open in
explorer. Đâu rồi?
Đâu ấy nhỉ?
Đây. Model.pk đâu ấy nhở? Đây đây này.
15,6 mấy
chưa? cũng không nhẹ đâu đúng không?
15,6 m được chưa? Thì bây giờ mình muốn
load nó ra, các bạn chú ý này, thật ra
ấy các bạn xếp một mình nó là chưa đủ.
Tại vì sao? Tại vì tí nữa ấy các bạn
muốn đem cái mô hình nó đi dự đoán ấy
thì cái thì cái dựa đồ vào ấy nó phải
qua cái bước tiền xử lý này. Cái bước
này này, cái bước scaler này tức là gì?
Các bạn phải xếp cả cái ông sceller này
nữa đúng không? Tí các bạn còn transform
mà. Đây này. Đây là lúc mình xest của
mình nhá. Đúng không? Xt test này là
mình đã phải qua cái bước xử lý này rồi
đúng không? Nên là xếp mỗi model là chưa
đủ. Phải xếp cả cái sceller nữa thì tí
mới có cái mà xài đúng không? Đây mình
xếp thành hai cái nhá. Đúng không? Moder
là 1 này đúng không? Scaler là 2 nhá.
Được chưa? Xếp hai cái này thì tí mới
lôi. Scaler là để tiền xử lý. Model là
để huấn luyện đúng không? Chạy này.
Chạy này.
Các bạn chờ tí nhá. Chờ dạy lâu nhá.
>> [hắng giọng]
>> Xong rồi nhá. Đúng không? Thì bây giờ
bây giờ mình sẽ bây giờ là bây giờ là
mình mình mình đã lưu được cái mô hình
này rồi. Đây cái model này là thật ra là
tên nó là model nhưng mà bên trong nó có
cả nó có cả cái scaler của mình. Được
chưa? Thì bây gi mình sẽ viết vào một
cái script mới nhá. Cái script mới tinh
này mình đặt tên nó là inference.
Influence trắng tình chả có cái gì cả
đúng không? Thì mình sẽ phải load cái m
load cái model này ra. Load thế nào đây
các bạn? Nhìn này. Load save thì dùng
picker thì load cũng dùng picker thôi.
Đây load cũng picker thôi. Đây nhá. Được
chưa? Import này. Picker nó thiếu cái
dòng
picker. Được chưa? Đây load nó ra đúng
không? Đây mình gọi là model nhá.
Mod là một này. Và thứ hai là cái gì?
Scor là 2. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ mình
sẽ test nhanh. Test nhanh mình phải giữa
tạo ra một cái dữ liệu fake để mình test
thử được chưa? P tức là nào? Tức là đây
các bạn thấy là các bạn có những cái
pancency glucoer này đúng không? Tức là
gì? Input các bạn phải cho một cái giá
trị input đầu vào của bốn của của tám
cái giá trị này đúng không? Pancency
này, glucoser pressure thứ này đấy đúng
không? Cho cái input này vào. Bây giờ
mình sẽ thử nhá. Mình thử này. Ví dụ là
fake input nhá. Được chưa? Bịa nó ra. Bị
bịa nó ra thì đây prancy glucoser
pressure.
Ví dụ nha. Ví dụ mình này mình chia chia
đôi ra nhìn nó dễ nhá.
Drive này được chưa? Ví dụ paty thì cho
là 2 đi được chưa? Glucozer cho bao
nhiêu nhỉ? Glucozer cho là 200 đi được
chưa? B special huyết áp huyết áp là 70
đi được chưa? Skin thích là cái độ dày
của da chả biết bao nhiêu đây cho 20 đi
đúng không? Mình cũng chả biết mấy em có
ý nghĩa gì mà thôi cho vào insulin.
Insulin cho 100
BMI cho 29,3 chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy
được chưa? Diabet pedigree function bao
nhiêu nhỉ? 0 phẩy mấy này mình cho là
0,5 đi. Được chưa? 0,5 đi. Được chưa? H
là bao nhiêu? H mình cho là 5 tuổi được
chưa? Và mình sẽ phải dự đoán được cái
outcome gì đúng không? Đây là cái fake
input của mình đúng không? Mình fake tám
cái dữ liệu input đồ vào này. Được chưa?
Bây giờ mình phải đưa nó vào trong mô
hình dự đoán này đúng không? Prediction
đúng không? bằng model chpdx này input
này. Theo các bạn bây giờ nếu mình chạy
nó có lỗi gì không? Nếu bây giờ mình
chạy luôn này, theo các bạn nó có lỗi gì
không?
Nó có chạy được không? Nếu bây giờ mình
ấn mình click chạy này, theo các bạn nó
có chạy được không?
Theo bạn có chạy được không?
>> Chạy được nhưng mà nó chưa chưa xử lý dữ
liệu.
>> Đúng chính xác. Nó chưa xử lý dữ liệu.
Cụ thể là gì? Mình chưa tiền xử lý. đúng
không?
F input bằng sceller
transform được chưa? Input như này được
chưa?
Theo các bạn cái dòng số 7 này liệu có
chạy được không? Dòng số 7 này theo bạn
liệu nó có chạy được không?
Theo bạn nóu liều nó có chạy được không?
Nà số 7 này
chạy được không?
Theo các bạn liệu nó có chạy được không?
>> Nó chưa fit.
>> Không cần fit. Thật ra không cần fit.
>> À đúng rồi.
>> Ừ không fit. Tại vì là nó nó fit từ lúc
trên rồi
>> đúng không các bạn? Đưa vào năm array ừ
thì cũng được. Th không đưa về n array
thì cũng ok.
cho vào n thì cũng được thôi nhưng mà để
ở list này không thì cũng ok nó chỉ nó
là một cái mảng thôi là ok rồi
các bạn cái fake input này nó đang là
mảng mấy chiều các bạn fake input nó
đang là mảng mấy chiều
đây là mảng mấy chiều
>> đó là mảng một chiều
>> một một chiều chính xác lúc trước lúc
chúng Test này. X test ở đây là mảng mấy
chiều?
>> Hai chiều.
>> Hai chiều đúng không?
Phải đưa nó về mảng hai chiều đã. Dễ làm
cái nào? Cho cái ngoặc nữa ở ngoài này.
Được chưa?
Ngặc cái này xong rồi. Đó.
Nó chạy thử này.
Xong rồi. Nhưng mà mình chưa in ra cái
gì cả đúng không? Chư là green này,
prediction này. Được chưa? Nhìn thử nhá.
1 được chưa? Tất nhiên mình có thể mình
lấy mình lấy cái nhân ở ở bên trong ra
thì mình cho ngoặc này ông này luôn. Nó
là một cái mảng một chiều thì nó chỉ có
một phần tử thôi mà. Đây đúng không?
Đây đúng không? Đây là cách để tôi có
thể tôi đem đi triển khai đấy đúng
không? Đem đi triển khai đúng không? Tôi
load cái mô hình đó tôi đã huấn luyện
sẵn rồi đúng không? Tôi cho rượu sle vào
đúng không? Mà tất ở đây là mình ngồi
máy của mình thôi. Mình chỉ ra cho khách
hàng mà làm thế này thì cũng được đúng
không? Thì khách hàng là gì? Tức là phải
có một cái server đúng không? Có một cái
server chạy ở đâu đấy các bạn chỉnh trên
AWS chẳng hạn đúng không? Khách nó sẽ
gửi request đến cái server đấy đúng
không? Thì bây giờ làm thế nào? Thì bây
giờ đấy mình chỉ các bạn vi coding đây
đúng không? Chả cần phải dùng close làm
gì. Dùng cái này dùng chat dùng chat GPT
là thừa nhá. Chat GPT đây được chưa
nhá. Đâ đầu tiên th vứt cái vứt vứt cái
file này vào. Vứt cái file này vào đây.
Đây các bạn dùng cái đơn giản này các
bạn dùng aid gì cũng được đây nhá. Inf
này đúng không?
Dễ nhá. Được chưa?
Có nhiều thư viện để giúp các bạn có thể
làm ui lắm nhá. Viết tiếng Việt nhá.
Viết tí cho dễ nhá.
Hãy
[âm nhạc] hãy viết cho tôi script.
Thường thì dùng UI này có mấy nó có mấy
cái thư viện, một là streamlist, hai là
radio thì mình sẽ dùng các bạn
streamlist là như này. Stream
list này. Tại vì mình dùng mình biết là
có cái này rồi. Đây app này nó dùng dễ
lắm này. Ờ cái này các bạn chả cần các
bạn cũng vèo vèo cái là xong thôi. Nhưng
mà đây mình dùng mình dùng streamlist
nhá. Đấy mình tạm cái app đây này kiểu
này. Đấy được chưa? Hãy hãy hãy hãy dùng
skre dùng
skin list để tạo cho tôi một t với
đơn giản cho
phép
người dùng nhập vào
giá trị
bao gồm
Bao gồm thầ lấy cái lấy cái tên ra nhỉ.
Tên đây mở cái file CSV này ra bao gồm à
chờ mình tí đâu rồi nhở.
Các bạn chờ tí mình mình
mở notepade đã. Open with đây hết đây
đây đúng không? Bao gồm
đâu rồi?
bao gồm
và
mô hình
tôi sẽ rửa đó để đưa ra
xem ngần có bị hiểu đường hay không đúng
không một bằng có 2 bằng 0 thế thôi dùng
s tạo ra một cái app đơn giản cho người
dùng nhật
Ok. Thế thôi đúng không? Ờ cái gì nhỉ? À
ờ
viết API viết API để chạy kiểu server
client. Cái này bạn nào các bạn không IT
nữ sẽ khó. Tức là tức là như này. Tức là
cái server của mình nó chạy cái nó đã
chạy cái model nó sẽ lắng nghe request
gửi đến từ người dùng đúng không? Thì
người dùng sẽ dùng cái app giống kiểu
bây giờ các bạn có một cái app AI các
bạn để trên server nhá. Cái app ví dụ là
chỉnh sử ảnh chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì
các bạn cần cái điện di động ấy là nó
chỉ cái phần UI để các bạn tương tác
thôi. Có bất kỳ cái request gì nã gửi
cái server đó đúng không? Một là có ừ à
ừ à một là có nhầm nhầm nhầm nhầm không
là không ở đây. Sorry đúng không? À hãy
dùng pass API để tạo API theo là
để triển khai theo để server client.
Thật ra thì có khi các bạn không biết
cái dòng này có khi nó cũng nó cũng tự
biết đường nó làm nhưng mà thôi mình
biết chắc nhá. Được chưa? này. À từ từ
quên bạn nào viết đơn đơn giản thôi nhìn
nó dễ.
Ơ sao không edit được ấ nhỉ?
Server các bạn dùng ở đâu cũng được các
bạn. Các bạn dùng sao lại
các bạn chờ tí lại phải ngồi đính server
các bạn thuê của SWS này nữa nhưng mà
tha
thật ra cái ứng dụng này các bạn không
cần phải dùng đến GPU thì các bạn dùng
máy vớ vẩn cũng được server không không
cần không cần có không cần phải có GPU
cũng được đâu inf đâu ấy nhở
nó cứ bị ấy nhỉ.
Sa bình thường nó phải cho sửa nhở sao
bên này chờ tí nhá. Bình thường phải cho
sửa sau đây.
Ờ ai dùng một
viết kế đơn giản nhất
đây là mình đang dùng trên web các bạn
nhá. Còn th các bạn các bạn nào các bạn
dùng antiravity thì nó sẽ có ngay một
cái panel bên cạnh các bạn bảo nó làm
luôn đúng không? Đây là mình dùng trên
web thì thôi các bạn các bạn dùng anti
gravity thì nó còn nhanh nữa đúng không?
Đây chưa?
Tại vì mình tắt hết rồi. Mình mình mình
tắt hết cái đưa liên quan đến AI rồi nên
mình gõ vào đây chứ còn bình thường các
bạn gõ này nó sẽ lâu đúng không? Các bạn
dùng anti dùng antigravity hoặc là các
bạn dùng close code thì nó sẽ đọc ngay
cái script của bạn ngay trong project
luôn. Được chưa?
Đây
API đây. Cái server đây này. Server đây
server.
Đây server đây.
App ừ ok.
Rồi một ông là API thì là server, app
thì là client. Được chưa?
Rồi hơi nhiều thứ. Đây nó sẽ phải cài
những cái thứ này. Được chưa? Đây là cái
thư viện dùng các bạn để các bạn tạo ra
cái API rất là nhanh. Streamlist là để
tạo ra cái UI. Đây mình mình copy nhá.
Copy nhá. Copy nhá. Abi nó là cái server
đây server đây
server nhá. Mình gọi server đi được
chưa? Cái nữa là client được chưa?
Client này
được chưa? Client thì nó chính là cái
app ở dưới này. Đấy cho vào đây chưa?
Chạy server nhá. Phải chạy cái server
trước. Chạy server đâu rồi? Đâu rồi? Đó.
Đây
hình như mình có những cái thư viện này
rồi mình không cài lại nữa chạy đây.
Rồi rồi nhá. Xong các đây client thì nó
sẽ giả lộ vấn đề vào đây
sợ lỗi đấy nhỉ.
Chờ một tí các bạn nhá. Xem là xem à rồi
gì đấy nh.
A dùng dùng nhấm tên mình đặt tên được
server. Được rồi. I
đây mình đ tại vì mình mình đổi tên
rồiên là server đúng không? Server mới
đúng đúng không? server này. Tại vì mình
đổi tên tên nó là API, mình đổi tên là
server. Đây, bây giờ mới đúng này.
Đấy, mở ra cái app này như này.
Bây giờ muốn dùng thì à đâu ấy nhỉ?
Muốn dùng thì đâu? À đây chạy một thê m
hai đây nhá.
Bây giờ mình muốn chạy ví dụ phía client
thì sao thì nó sẽ chạy như này. Client
nó sẽ chạy như này. Hiện tại thì mình
đang server client cùng một chỗ nhưng mà
thực tế là nó sẽ phải client sẽ phải chỏ
đến IP của server đây.
À cũng không phải app mình gọi mình đặt
tên là client.
Client như thế này nhá. Run client được
chưa?
Được nó hơi nó hơi nó hơi nó hơi nó hơi
phức tạp. Các bạn dùng flash cũng được.
Cái gì thế này
đây.
Đấy đúng không các bạn? Nhập số vào đây
này. Đ cộng lại cho cộng trừ này rồi
đây. Điền vào đây đúng không?
Ví dụ mình cho tăng làm 3 nhá. A này
được chưa? GER này đấy. Víx này
đấy kết quả dự đoán này. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ thì chả ai người ta ngồi
người ta thích cái UI bằng tay cả. UI
thì bây giờ các bạn đẩy lên đây là các
bạn dùng dùng dùng dùng dùng dùng các
bạn dùng vạch coding nó rất là nhanh
đúng không? Đây đây là còn chưa tối ưu
gì về UI các bạn nhá. Chưa tối ưu gì cả.
Được chưa? Đấy tức là gì? Sau này ấy các
bạn sẽ thuê một cái server đúng không?
Đây là cái hiện tại là cái server nó
đang nó đang chạy local thế này. Các bạn
đang chạy loc thì các bạn sẽ thấy là cái
địa chỉ 127.01 này. Nhưng mà giúp các
bạn chạy một cái server đấy nó sẽ có một
cái địa chỉ khác đúng mấy chấm cái thứ
làng nhằng đấy đúng không? Chạy một cái
server trên đấy. Server là nơi chạy cái
model và model sẽ lắng nghe cái request
đến từ người dùng. Thế thì khi mà người
dùng họ chạy cái họ họ họ họ mở cái app
này ra ấy đúng không? Thì họ sẽ có cái
khi mà họ khi mà họ ấn vào khi mà họ ấn
vào cái chữ PR này ấ thì nó sẽ gửi một
cái request này. Cái request này lúc đấy
nhá lúc mà các bạn triển khai thực tế
thì cái địa chỉ IP này nó sẽ không phải
như này. Tại vì đây là đây là đang đang
chạy local đúng không? Chạy chạy local
tức là server cù một chỗ. Trong thực tế
thì server nó sẽ một cái chỗ nào đấy
mình sẽ thay cái địa chỉ server vào đây.
Cổng hay là cổng 8000 hoặc cổng gì đấy
khác đúng không? Nó sẽ gửi request đến
server. Server nó xử xong server sau đấy
nó nhận được cái request này xong đúng
không? Nó nhận được cái request xong
đây này nhận request xong nó sẽ đây này
cái cái request nó gửi đến đây xong đúng
không? Đây này ông client này gửi cái pr
này đúng không? Đấy thì ông server ông
ấy xử lý đúng cái endpix này xong ông ấy
sẽ trả về trả về đây này trả về đây này
đấy đúng không? Mining cái thứ từ đ trả
về và ông cái ông đấy nhận xong cái nhận
xong cái respond này ông đấy trả về ông
đấy show ra thôi. này sâu ra này xong
rồi đây đây kết quả các thứ này đấy chưa
đấy nó sâu ra như này được chưa đấy thì
đây là cách để các bạn làm cái app các
bạn cho người ta người dùng
khi mình xây dựng xong model và đưa ra
mô hình dự đoán làm sao để người dùng có
thể chấp nhận kết quả mô hình dự đoán
của mình thì mình phải chứng minh cho
người ta là kết quả mình nó đáng tin cậy
tức là gì trước khi trước khi người dùng
họ dùng ấy chúng ta sẽ phải biết chúng
phải show người ta là gì là cái môi hình
ảnh của tôi đã được đem đã được kiểm
chứng đã độ chính xác là bao nhiêu? Ví
dụ như vậy, ví dụ như mình bọn mình chào
hàng cho khách hàng cái sản phẩm về bóng
đá nhá. Đúng không? Như này ví dụ như
này chẳng hạn, ví dụ như này
đúng không? Để họ dùng thì phải cho họ
tin đi đã, đúng không? Để họ dùng phải
cho họ tin đã đúng không? Đây ví dụ bọn
mình sẽ cho bọn họ cái demo này. Tức là
mình bảo khách hàng là đây anh các anh
cho cho tôi một cái video demo. Tôi sẽ
phân tích cho các anh đây. Phân tích
demo mình gửi này xong mình sẽ có những
cái thống kê là cầu thủ chạy thế này,
thế này các thứ đúng không? Mình phải
chứng minh cho họ là gì? Sản phẩm mình
nó đáng tin cậy không thì họ sẽ dùng.
Tất nhiên điều này không phải lúc nào
cũng dễ nhất là cái thời buổi ngày nay
các bạn thấy là có geni các bạn có mô
hình ngôn ngữ lớn các bạn xây dựng cái
mô hình kiểu r chatb chẳng hạn chứng
minh nó sẽ khó hơn tại vì là
tại vì vậy là với ra chatbot ấy nó không
có câu câu trả lời là đúng tuyệt đối với
sai tuyệt đối đúng không cùng cái câu
hỏi thì mô hình nó sẽ trả lời một cái nó
tìm thông tin từ tài liệu chẳng hạn đúng
thì cái việc kểu ra đúng sai nó sẽ khó
hơn nhưng mà chúng ta sẽ phải là chúng
ta chúng ta convince chúng ta thuyết
phục người dùng là gì Cái của tôi nó
đáng tin cậy đúng không?
Giống như kiểu ngày xưa cái hồi đầu chat
GPT nó mới ra mắt đấy. Open cho chúng ta
dùng miễn phí đấy để ch để chúng ta thấy
đá tin cậy trước đúng không? Đang tin
cậy rồi tốt rồi người ta mới vào người
ta mới bắt đầu được thu tiền của mình
cũng thế. Và sản phẩm là gì? Giai đạn
đầu cho họ dùng thử một vài tháng free
họ trải nghiệm đúng không? Dùng free thì
có ông nào chê đâu đúng không? Của free
thì có ai chê đâu đúng không? Họ dùng
rồi họ lấy tốt thì sau đó mình thu phí.
Ok.
Nhưng tất nhiên cái vai trò của mình
trong công ty mình là kỹ sư ai cái nhiệm
vụ của mình là không phải không phải là
đi thuyết phục. Nhiệm vụ mình làm sao
cho cái mình nó càng tốt, cải thiện tốt.
Còn cái việc là cho khách hàng dùng free
1 tháng hay là 3 tháng, discount như thế
nào, marketing nào thì đấy là việc của
cái team bên kia. Đấy, còn mình là kỹ
thuật là mình chỉ thuần về thôi. Nhưng
mà nhưng mà ý là một công ty vận động
hành nó thường thường là nó sẽ như thế
đó. Nó sẽ như thế
thì thôi các bạn ông này dùng áp rất là
nhanh đúng không? Tức là cái phần ph thì
nó dễ phần back end thì nó mới thẳng
nhằng còn ph dễ lắm đúng không?
Đấy và thông thường là ví dụ các bạn nào
các bạn quen code thì các bạn biết là
chúng ta sẽ thường là chúng ta sẽ dùng
ai nó đất đình ngay trong ngay trong
ngay trong IDE đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn
dùng VS Code hoặc các bạn các bạn dùng
antigravity nó sẽ có một cái panel ở
phía bên phải này đúng không? Một cái
panel phía bên phải AI các bạn hỏiỏỏi
bạn hỏi ở đấy đúng không? Đây mình tắt
trừ rồi mình tắt rồi không mình bật nó
lên là nó cũng sẽ có một cái pan ở bên
phải này mình sẽ hỏi n bảo đây tạo cho
tôi một cái UI này nó sẽ tạo ra ngay chứ
không có chuyện các bạn phải đi ngồi các
bạn copy paste này đâu đúng không? Copy
paste này chỉ là cái thứ kiểu con con
con thôi chứ còn khi mà project nó có
cái cấu trúc rồi copy paste này nó tốn
thời gian lắm đúng không?
Rồi ok có câu hỏi gì không? Qua có thắc
mắc gì không?
Thế nhá. Thế bây giờ mình sẽ mình sẽ nói
qua một chút về bài tập về nhà. Chúng ta
sẽ ngồi mình cho các bạn ba bộ dữ liệu
cho các bạn ba bộ dữ liệu. Ngay bây giờ
trên lớp mình sẽ ngồi mình sẽ phân tích
luôn một bộ và sau đó về nhà các bạn sẽ
chọn một trong ba bộ để các bạn làm nhá.
Dữ liệu thì mình đã up trên trên Google
Drive rồi. Dữ liệu của chúng ta thì nó
có như này.
Nói qua một tí.
Ờ mình sẽ nói qua một chút về rượu chúng
ta. Đầu tiên cái bộ mà mình muốn giới
thiệu các bạn ngay nó là cái bộ này.
Bạn chờ mình tí nhá.
Đầu tiên là cái bộ này. Bộ này các bạn
cho mình hỏi này. Đây cái bộ này. Đầu
tiên C L cho mình hỏi có bạn nào các bạn
nhìn cái tên bộ này các bạn biết là nó
về cái gì các bạn cho mình số 1. Còn bạn
nào các bạn nhìn cái tên các bạn không
biết nó về cái gì cho mình số 0. Đây nà
chỗ chuột mình đây này bạn nào các bạn
nhìn cái tên này các bạn biết là nó là
liệu về cái gì cho mình số một xem nào.
Còn các bạn nhìn cái tên các bạn không
luận ra nó là cái gì cho mình dù không.
Ok là một diệu về game đúng không? Đây
là game ưa thích của mình rất là thích
game này nhá. Đúng không? Hôm đây không
phải không phải về customer đâu. Đây
không phải customer. Đây là ví dụ về
game. Về game chắc là lớp mình chắc phải
có một vài bạn biết chơi cái game này
đúng không? Hình như là ở Việt Nam cái
game này nó không phổ biến lắm nhưng mà
ở ở bên châu Âu ở ở Đức ý đây là game
rất rất phổ biến đấy. Bọn bạn Châu Âu nó
chơi game này nhiều lắm. Việt Nam mình
có vẻ không phổ biến lắm. Thì vậy thấy
mình thấy có vẻ không phổ biến lắm. Game
này nói về một cái tựa game tên là ên là
CS:GO bây giờ nó gọi là CS2 rồi đúng
không? Game này mô tả như nào các bạn
nhở? Game này lớp xe có những bạn bạn
các bạn không biết cái game này đúng
không? Game này nó như nào các bạn nhở?
Game này tức là gì? Tức là nó sẽ có hai
phe nhở. Nó có hai phe đúng không? Một
phe là phe khủng bố và một phe là phe
chống khủng bố đúng không? Bên Nam mình
hay gọi là phe cảnh với phe cướp đấy
đúng không? Cảnh với cướp. Thế thì hai
phe mỗi phe sẽ có năm người đúng không?
Mỗi phe sẽ có năm người. Ừ. Hai phe có
năm người. Phe terrorist là phe khủng
bố. Counter terrorist là chống khủng bố.
Đúng không? Ta gọi là T và và CT đúng
không? T là khủng bố. City là chống
khủng bố. Có lẽ mở game ra đi nhìn nó dễ
nhờ. Mở game nhìn rõ cái này nói khó quá
nhờ. Mở game ra nhìn nó dễ nhá. Hình như
hình như cũng đang có giải đấy. Nào xem
nhá.
Đây game lại như th này các bạn chưa?
Đây game lại như này nhá. Game như th
này đấy nó sẽ có hai phe được chưa? Mỗi
phe có năm người đúng không? Lớp có nh
bạn các bạn biết rồi nhưng mà có nh bạn
chưa biết mình nói qua đúng không? Mỗi
bên có năm người. Nhiệm vụ rất là đơn
giản.
Ừ nhiệm [hắng giọng] vụ rất đơn giản. À
cái phe khủng bố ấy thì nó sẽ có quả bom
đúng không? Quả quả gọi là quả bom C4
đúng không? Quả C4 thì nhiệm vụ nó là
gì? Nó phải đặt được quả bom đấy đúng
không? Một là nó phải đặt được quả bom,
hai là nó giết hết đối phương. phe cảnh
sát, phe chống củ bố thì cũng nhệ vụ
tương tự gì. Một là giết hết được đối
phương, hai là nếu mà đối phương đặt bom
rồi thì mình phải gỡ được bom. Đấy,
nhiệm vụ của hai nó như thế đúng không?
Thì đấy là cái game này. Được chưa? Cái
game này thì thời ngày xưa thời ngày xưa
thì thì nó hãy chơi theo kiểu là ví dụ
các bạn vào nó sẽ có tổng cộng là 30
round đúng không? 15 round các bạn đ
chơi ở phe này, xong 15 round các bạn đ
chơi ở phe kia. Rồi maximum các bạn sẽ
chơi 30 round như thế. Thế thì đây là
đây là cái bộ dữ liệu đây là cái bộ dữ
liệu về các cái game nó đã được record
lại vào năm 2018 có những cái cái các
cái thông số thông tin như này được
chưa?
Thế thì bây giờ ấy nó có một cái cột rất
là quan trọng là là cột resource. Resort
nó chỉ có ba kết quả thôi. Một là thắng,
hai là thua và ba là hòa đúng không? Thế
bây giờ giả sử đi mình đang muốn luyện
tập cho bài toán phân loại đi thì mình
sẽ làm gì? Mình sẽ huấn luyện một cái mô
hình để làm sao mô hình này nó có thể dự
án xem là dựa vào tất cả những thông tin
đầu vào nó dự án xem là kết quả đầu ra
nó là kết quả thắng hòa hay là thua.
Được chưa?
Nhưng mà các bạn chú ý này đúng không?
Bộ này cũng giống như là cái bộ debt.
Cái việc các bạn chọn cái cột là là cái
gì nó sẽ quyết định xem là bài toán nó
là bài toán gì. Các bạn chọn cột
resource là cột tag it thì nó sẽ là bài
toán phân loại. Các bạn chọn cột po là
cột tagit nó sẽ là bài toán hồi quy. Hồi
quy thì buổi sau chúng ta sẽ sẽ thực
hành đến bài toán hồi quy. Được chưa?
Thế nhưng quay lại đây các bạn chú ý
này, trong data và machining ấy chúng ta
sẽ có những cái bộ dữ liệu
trong cái bài toán vừa rồi bộ dữ liệu ta
chúng ta có chín cột, chúng ta có tám
cột là input và một cột là cái target
đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ dùng tám cột
input để chúng ta dựng cái target. Trong
thực tế không phải là có bao nhiêu dữ
liệu các bạn sẽ phải dùng từng đấy.
Trong thực tế các bạn sẽ phải quyết định
xem là những cái cột nào các bạn cần các
bạn giữ lại. Cột nào các bạn thấy là nó
có liên quan, nó có ảnh hưởng đến cái
tắc đầu ra các bạn giữ lại. Cột nào các
bạn thấy là nó hoàn toàn nó nó chả liên
quan gì đến cái đầu ra thì các bạn sẽ bỏ
đi đúng không? Chứ không phải là dữ liệu
có cái gì các bạn cũng dùng được. này là
một data scientist có nhiều thông tin,
có nhiều dữ liệu thì là tốt nhưng vấn đề
nó chỉ tốt khi mà cái rượu này nó quan
trọng thôi. Còn nếu dữ liệu nó không
quan trọng nó không liên quan thì thì
chả dùng để làm gì cả. Ví dụ các bạn xem
một cái mô hình để dự án giá nhà
để dán dẫn để để dán dận giá nhà.
Thì nếu mà các bạn có một cái thông tin
là nhà này nó có nhà này người ta có lắp
người ta có thảm chùi chân không chẳng
hạn thì cái thông tin thì nó chả liên
quan đến giá căn nhà thì các bạn bỏ đi
đúng không? Thế thì bây giờ ở đây nó
cũng thế. Bây giờ giả sử mình muốn xem
một cái mô hình để xem dự đoán xem là
cái kết quả của cái trận đấu này tức là
mỗi một hàng, mỗi một hàng nó là thông
tin của một người chơi đúng không? Mỗi
một hàng là thông tin của một người chơi
của một trận đấu, của một ngày nào đấy
đúng không? Tất nhiên nó từ lâu rồi,
2018 rồi đúng không? Thì bây gi chúng ta
sẽ muốn dựa cái bộ rượu này để chúng ta
xây dựng cái mô hình chúng ta huấn luyện
nó để nó dự đoán kết quả của trận đấu
đúng không? Thì bây giờ chúng ta sẽ phải
xem là theo các bạn bây giờ chúng ta có
từng nể cột nhưng mà không phải cột nào
cũng quan trọng, không phải cột nào cũng
cần. Chúng xem là chúng ta sẽ giữ cột
nào, chúng ta bỏ cột nào. Được chưa?
Ừ. Thế bây chúng ta đi qua từng cột một
nhá. Đi qua từng cột. Cột đầu tiên là
cột map. Map là gì? Map là bản đồ. Được
chưa? Bản đồ dành cho những bạn nào các
bạn chưa biết thì bản đồ trông nó như
này chưa? Lớp thì các bạn biết rồi mà
cũng có bạn các bạn chưa biết đúng
không? Bản đồ
đây. Bản đồ chốc nó như này. Tức là nó
sẽ có nhiều cái cái hình nào dễ nhìn một
tí nhỉ?
Đây nó kia kiểu thế này tức là nó tức là
nó sẽ có cái nhiều nó sẽ có nhiều cái
bản đồ để để chơi đúng không? Nhiều bản
đồ để chơi đúng không? Thế bây giờ theo
các bạn theo các bạn bây giờ với một cái
mô hình chúng ta dự đoán
kết quả trận đấu này theo các bạn cái
cột bản đồ này thì các bạn chúng ta giữ
là bỏ nếu các bạn rất là chắc chắn là
cái cột này nó chả liên quan gì đến kết
quả thì các bạn bỏ đi. Còn nếu các bạn
thấy là nó có liên quan hoặc các bạn
không chắc thì các bạn giữ lại đúng
không? Chỉ khi nào các bạn chắc chắn
rằng nó chẳng liên quan gì đến kết quả
thì các bạn bỏ đi.
Đó. Mà thật ra nhá, sau này các bạn đi
làm các bạn lại thấy là gì? Nhiều khi ấ
nó sẽ không có câu trả lời đúng hay sai
tuyệt đối đâu. Nhiều khi nó chỉ là cái
cảm nhận, cái phân tích của mỗi người
thôi. Tức là nhiều khi là với người này
người ta nghĩ là là quan trọng, người
kia nghĩ là không. Thì nó chỉ hơn nhau
là cái việc chúng ta sẽ discus, chúng ta
sẽ thảo luận với nhau xem là chúng ta
nên giữ hay là nên bỏ. Theo các bạn cái
này cả cái bộ này mình sẽ không nói là
là cái ý của mình là là đúng. Mình chỉ
nói là nếu là mình thì mình sẽ làm như
thế nào nhá. Nào các bạn có cụp mép này
giữ hay bỏ nào? Mép giữ hay bỏ?
>> Giữ.
>> Ừ khác thì sao?
Với mình thì à mình cũng không rõ là cái
map đúng là thường ai cũng sẽ có một
phải cái mép tủ. Mình cũng không rõ lắm
cái mép này liệu nó có giúp gì cho kết
quả không nhưng mà mình cũng không có
cái bằng chứng gì để mình bảo là cái của
m đó nó chẳng liên quan gì cả nên là
mình sẽ giữ đúng không?
Ờ tại vì chúng ta cũng không biết là cái
người trên này nó họ tủ cái map gì nhưng
mà mình cũng không có cái lý do gì để
mình không có một cái lý do gì rất là
chắc chắn để mình bỏ điên mình sẽ giữ
được chưa mình sẽ giữ được chưa phép là
giữ nào ngày tháng năm ngày tháng năm
theo các bạn
question à cái này không nên các bạn cái
đây là cái bước chúng ta lọc trước tức
là gì đây là cái bước mà chúng ta dùng
cái gọi là dùng domain knowledge đúng
không tức là tất nhiên các bạn dùng
coration thì nó cũng có cái nhưng mà đây
là lúc bạn dùng domain knowledge dùng
cái kiến thức thực tế của các bạn là các
bạn quyết định đúng không? Coation không
phải lúc nào sau này chúng ta sẽ dùng
nhưng mà bước này là cái bước chúng ta
đang gọi là đang lọc bằng cơm đấy đúng
lọc bằng cơm là lọc bằng cái knowledge
của chúng ta đấy đúng không? Question
chúng ta sẽ để sau đúng không? Ai thì nó
sẽ tính sau nhưng mà mình sẽ dùng con
người trước được chưa?
Định lượng phân tích như nào? Định lượng
phân tích như nào?
Đây là coation đúng không? Mình thấy
tính ở phía sau đúng không? Đây cái đừng
bị phụ thuộc quá vào máy móc mô hình
đúng không? Cái này chúng cái chúng ta
có thể xử lý được mà đúng không? Đúng
không các bạn? Nếu sử dụng xây dựng một
cái mô hình mà đưa cái thông tin vào nó
chả liên quan gì chúng ta bỏ đi đúng
không? Đây là cái thứ chúng ta con người
làm được mà đúng không? Đừng quá phụ
thuộc vào máy móc đúng không? Đây là
bước ch con người có thể làm được đúng
không? Đây là thứ con người làm được mà
đúng không? Dựa vào kiến thức của chúng
ta làm được mà đúng không? Trừ phi các
bạn chả biết gì về game này thì thôi
đành chịu. Còn không có biết về game này
các bạn có thể làm được mà đúng không?
Con người ch con người làm được cái gì
thì chúng ta cứ làm chứ tội gì đúng
không? Nào, ngày tháng năm giữ hay bỏ
các bạn?
Ừ, theo mình cũng là bỏ chả thấy nó liên
quan gì cả đúng không? Mình cũng chưa
thấy một cái mối quan hệ gì việc là ngày
tháng năm chơi việc thắng hòa thua đúng
không? Mình chơi ngày nào mình cũng có
thể thua được đúng không? Chả có ngày
nào là ngày dễ thắng, ngày dễ thua. Ngày
nào cũng có thể thua đúng không? Deate
mình cũng bỏ luôn. Deate thì là gộp ba
kia lại thôi. Được không nào các bạn? W
time. W time có ý nghĩa gì? W time là
cái gì? Thời gian đợi. Thân đợi là cái
gì?
Nào bạn nào có thể giải thích được cái
thời thần đệ này có ý nghĩa gì không?
Không phải chết đợi hồ sinh đâu. Không
phải
đây không phải đây không phải thời gian
chết xong đợi hồi sinh đâu. Đợi ghép
trận. Đúng rồi. Tại vì sao? Chúng ta vào
chơi chúng ta chỉ có một mình thôi nhưng
mà phải ghép với chín người khác đúng
không? Không phải chúng ta cứ muốn chơi
là chơi được ngay. Phải ghép đúng không?
Phải chờ th ghép ch loading nó tìm trận
đúng không?
Theo các bạn cái cột web này giữ hay bỏ?
ghép lâu gặp team pro nhưng mà ghép lâu
gặp team pro nhưng mà khả năng cao khi
mà mình được ghép với team pro thì có
nghĩa là nếu mà nếu mà đối thủ pro thì
có nghĩa là sao các bạn? Nếu mà các bạn
được ghép vào đối thủ pro thì có nghĩa
là các bạn làm sao?
>> Đồng đội của mình cũng pro. Ừ mình cũng
pro mà đúng không? Nó ghép nó sẽ ghép
cân bằng mà các bạn đúng không? Nó pro
mình cũng pro mà lo gì đúng không? Đúng
không? À lớp trước của mình cũng có
những bạn mới bảo là time lâu thì em
không được patient cho lắm.
Thế nhưng nếu là mình nếu là mình thì
mình sẽ
mình sẽ bỏ. Tại vì theo mình là cái wứ
nó xảy ra trước khi trận đấu bắt đầu
đúng không? Mình lâu thì thằng kia cũng
lâu mà mấy thằng kia nó cũng lâu mà đúng
không? Chín thằng kia nó cũng phải đợi
chứ có phải thằng nào được vào ngay đâu.
Đúng không? Theo mình nếu là mình mình
sẽ bỏ mình thấy nó [hắng giọng] chưa
liên quan lắm đến cái trận đấu. Được
chưa
nào? Tiếp theo nào. Cụ thể tiếp theo là
cột quan trọng về khó này. Mam m tính
bằng dây. Đây là cái gì các bạn? M đây
là gì?
>> Thời gian giết ra trận đấu.
>> Thời gian chơi trận đấu. Chính xác. Từ
lúc đầu lúc bạn mới vào cho lúc mà thắng
thua ngã ngũ đúng không? Nào các bạn m
sam giữ bỏ
nào. Theo các bạn m theo các bạn giữ hay
bỏ.
Các bạn nhìn này. Hơn cái cột này nhá.
Lớp mình là lớp số bao nhiêu nhỉ? Lớp
mình là lớp số 21 đúng không nhỉ? Lớp
mình số 21.
Ngày xưa ấy cho đến khoảng 15 16 cái lớp
đầu ấy lúc mình dạy đến cái bài này ấ
lúc nào cái hướng của mình cũng là bỏ
cái cột này. Vì sao mình lại bảo bỏ? Tại
vì mình lộ lợn này nhá. Ngày xưa cách
mình lộ luận là gì? Mình bảo là tôi bỏ
cột mở vì sao? Các bạn cứ tưởng tượng mà
xem. Trong một trận đấu bình thường,
trong một trận đấu bình thường, 10 người
chơi bình thường thì cái m time của 10
người này là như nào các bạn? Hả các
bạn? Trong một trận đấu mà 10 người
không ai không ai bỏ game sớm thì cái
màng của 10 người là như nào? Là như
nhau.
Là như nhau. Và trong một trận đấu có 10
người thì thông thường sẽ có năm người
thắng và năm người thua. Đúng không?
Đúng rồi. Thế v các bạn cứ thử nghĩ xem
thế bây giờ m time của 10 ông này như
nhau trong đó có năm ông thắng năm ông
thua thì làm sao tôi dựa vào m time để
tôi dự đoán được xem là ông ấy thắng hay
ông ấy thua được đúng không? Thế nên là
ngày xưa mình luôn luôn lập ra c hướng
này là gì? Là vì m time của 10 trong một
trận là như nhau nên tôi sẽ không dựa
vào nó để tôi biết là thắng thua như nào
được đúng không? Đấy ngày xưa mình lận
như thế là mình thì mình sẽ bỏ.
Nhưng mà c mình học cái lớp số 16 ấy có
một bạn bãi bảo là bạn muốn giữ cái cột
này. Tại vì sao? Tại vì bạn bảo là cái m
time này ấy nó mà lâu
thì làm sao? Nếu cái m lâu thì làm sao?
Thì đầu càng ừ sao nữa?
M là tổng thời gian của tất cả các round
nhá.
Vẫn chưa phải cái điểm vẫn chưa phải cái
phải cái điểm trạng mình muốn. Nếu m lâu
mà lớn thì làm sao? Thì
thì làm sao
m lâu thì làm sao?
À đúng rồi. Khả năng cao chạy đây nó sẽ
hòa.
Khả năng cao chạy đên nó sẽ hòa.
Khả năng cao nó sẽ hòa. Đây nó chưa tính
overtime các bạn. Chưa tính overtime tức
là gì? Tức là mọi người hay chỉ để ý đến
thắng với thua thôi nhưng chúng ta quên
mất là gì? Là cái đây là mô hình dự án
kết quả và kết quả thì đâu phải chỉ có
thắng với thua đúng không? Đúng là thông
thường mọi người rất hay để ý thắng với
thua nhưng ta quên mất còn ông hòa nữa
đúng không? Thời gian lâu không chắc là
sẽ hòa nhưng càng lâu thì khả năng hòa
nó sẽ cao hơn. Ví dụ nhá các bạn nhìn ví
dụ nhá. Nhìn này. Ví dụ này các bạn cứ
để ý mà xem những cái trận mà dưới 3000
nhá. Ví dụ đây nhá trận đầu tiên này
nhá. 2009 này. Thắng này đúng không? 200
thua đúng không? Đấy thắng thua các thứ
nhá đúng không? 20073 thứ nhá các bạn.
Nhìn này 300 này nhìn này. 300 chưa? Cao
độ biến chưa? Trên 3000 này đúng không?
Mấy ông kia thấp này 3000 này hòa chưa
đúng không? Ông này thì là 3000 16 14
này cũng suýt suất hòa đúng không? Ờ
dưới nữa ông nào cao hẳn đi? Ông nào cao
hẳn đi. Ông nào cao hẳn đi. Đây đây các
bạn nhìn này. Ông này à đâu ấ nhở? Đâu
ông? Ông đây ông này đi. Đây các bạn này
lại hòa này. 300 này hòa rồi đây này.
Hòa rồi đúng không? Gì nữa? Thế là cao
hẳn đi.
Đây này. 300 này lại hòa rồi này.
Được chưa?
Xem còn cái gì cao cao nữa không?
Đây này.
300 này lại hòa thế này.
Ừ hòa thì cũng cũng là một kết quả mà
đúng không? Giờ ch bóng đá cũng thế
thôi. Có có thắng hòa thua mà đúng
không? Tất nhiên hòa là kết quả chúng ta
hay ít để ý nhưng mà nó là một kết quả
mà đúng không? Nó có thể là được nó có
thể là làm đứa con ghẻ trong đầu chúng
ta nhưng mà nó cũng là một nó cũng là
một kết quả mà đúng không? Đấy thì bạn
ấy bảo là gì? Là em dựa vào cái này em
sẽ biết là trận nào nó dễ hòa hơn.
Không hợp lý mà đúng không? Kết quả trận
đấu chỉ thắng hòa thua đâu. À có chu chỉ
có thắng mới thua đâu. Có cả hòa nữa
đúng không? Thế nên là từ lớp 16 mình
thay đổi luôn cái kết quả kết luận mình
trước cái lớp đấy trước đấy chưa từng
bạn nào lập luận mình là gì là dựa vào m
time này để ý đến hòa. Mọi người chỉ bàn
luận xung quanh thắng mới thua thôi. Đấy
và lớp 16 có bạn để ý đến cái hòa mình
cũng chưa bao gi mình để đến kết quả
hòa. Mình cũng chỉ để thắng thua thôi
đó. Nhưng chúng ta đúng là chúng ta có
kết quả hòa mà đúng không? Và thực sự là
gì? Nếu con người chúng ta chúng ta nhìn
được cái việc là gì? Nếu con nhìn được
cái việc là cái thời gian này nó lớn ấy
thường nó hòa cao thì mô hình chắc chắn
nó cũng sẽ nhìn được. Chắc chắn mô hình
nó sẽ nhìn được cái này đúng không?
Nh chưa? Nên là nhiều khi cái việc là
giữ bỏ cái gì ờ nó không có đúng cái xe
tuyệt tuyệt đối đâu. Nó chỉ là gì? Lập
luận của chúng ta. Lập luận đúng không?
Giữ đúng không? Giữ. Nó không giúp biết
thắng với nó sẽ không biết giúp thắng
với thua đâu. Tại vì là chúng ta còn
không biết là của bên team nào. Các bạn
nhìn nhá. Ví dụ nhá các bạn nhìn này.
Cái cầu team A về team B ấy cũng không
dựa vào được. Tại vì này ở đây nhá. Cái
hàng đầu tiên này team là 16 thì nó là
thắng. Hàng thứ hai cũng là team AR là
16 này là thua nên là cái cột team A
team B cũng bỏ luôn tại vì là không dựa
vào nó được đúng không? Cái này là nó
cũng không liên quan đúng không? Tại vì
có cái hàng là player thuộc team A, có
cái hàng player thuộc team B không dựa
vào nó được đúng không? Thế như đế là
chúng ta có gì? Map là giữ được này đúng
không? M time là giữ được này. Thế ăn
chơi giữ được đúng không? Thế còn mấy
cột đây các thứ này, w time với cả team
A, team B round thì bỏ đi đúng không?
Được chưa? Đúng không? Đấy nó các bạn
không cái này nó thực sự là nó sẽ đòi
cái có thể bây giờ các bạn vứt vào AI nó
sẽ luận cho các bạn nhưng mà nhưng mà rõ
ràng nó là cái thứ nó phải nó phải suy
luận đúng không? Chứ không phải là các
bạn nhìn đúng không? W time và m time
đều là thời gian cả nhưng mà một ông bỏ
một ông giữ đúng không? Đấy. Nào, ping
các bạn. Ping giữ hay là bỏ? Ping là cái
gì nhở? Ping là cái gì? Đầu tiên ping là
cái gì ta?
Đúng rồi. Team 15. Thế nhưng mà mình sẽ
bỏ cộ này. Tại sao? Thì cộ này mình dựa
vào nó thì nó không ấy lắm tại vì là
chúng ta không biết play g đây. Hai cột
này là nghĩa là ờ với những bài tập thì
người sẽ bỏ ra đúng không? Người ta sẽ
bỏ ra. Tại vì là thật ra ấy các bạn chú
ý này, hai cột này ấ muốn giữ cũng không
giữ được. Tại vì sao? Tại vì đây là hai
cột. Chúng ta sẽ sẽ chỉ biết khi mà biết
kết quả rồi, tức là xong kết quả rồi,
hết trận đấu rồi mới biết. Còn lúc chúng
ta muốn dự đoán ấy là chúng ta sẽ chưa
có hai ông này, đúng không? Dự đoán
chúng ta chưa có hai có hai rồi thì thì
còn gì đâu mà dự đoán đúng không? Ping
là ừ độ trễ các các bạn biết là ping nó
có biết là cái ping này nó tính như nào
không? Có ai biết cách tính ping là máy
nó sẽ làm cái gì đó tính từ ping không?
Ping là bây giờ xem là máy bạn nó cái
đường truyền mạng nó nhanh hay chậm. Các
bạn biết máy nó tính bằng cái nào không?
Máy tính của chúng ta nó tính cái ping
bằng cách nào?
Bằng cái nào các bạn?
Máy ch tính ping nó tính bằng cái nào
này?
>> Thời gian đẩy request trừ thời gian
>> à. Ừ đúng rồi đúng rồi. Nó sẽ gửi một
cái bó gói bé bé bé bé đúng không? Nó
gửi đến server cho server nó phản hồi
lại nó cộng trung bình chia đôi đúng
không? Cái này đúng không? Thế ping này
nó càng thấp thì càng tốt đúng không?
Giữ hay bỏ các bạn? Ping này giữ hay bỏ
đây? Pink này giữ hay bỏ đây?
Giữ đúng không?
>> Giữ
>> giữ. Ping thấp tốt. Hồi ngày xưa lúc mà
mình ở bên kia nhá. Mình chơi với bạn
mình ở server, bạn mình ở Hàn Quốc thì
chắc là chơi server Châu Á thôi. Ping
phải đến hơn 300 lúc và bên kia không
chơi với server Việt Nam được. Tại vì
ping nó cao quá đúng không? Ping cao thì
bên chơi ping thấp thì nó sẽ dễ hơn đúng
không? Ping dữ đúng không? Nào khi axit
với cả de đúng không? Số lần mạng giết,
số mạng hỗ trợ và số mạng chết. Giết với
cả chết thì dễ rồi. Hỗ trợ thế nào trong
CS:GO thế nào được gọi là hỗ trợ các
bạn? Assist thế nào được gọi là hỗ trợ
đây?
Thế nào gọi là hỗ trợ?
Gây đam đúng không? Gây đam nhưng không
chết đồng đội nó giết hộ cho đúng không?
Thì đấy đúng không? Ừ. Flash lùng gì đấy
đúng không? Ừ. Đúng không? Hỗ trợ đồng
đội giết đối phương. Hiểu một cách đơn
giản như vậy đúng không? Rồi bao này giữ
nhỉ? Quan trọng không? B này thông tin
quan trọng này đúng không? Mình mà giết
nhiều thì khả năng cao là team mình
thắng đúng không? Khả năng cao hơn thôi
đúng không? Giết nhiều khả năng cao team
mình thắng. Được không? MVP. MVP là cái
gì các bạn? MVP là cái gì nhỉ?
MVP là cái gì?
Xuất sác nhất round. Đúng rồi đúng
không? Xuất nhất cái round đấy. Mình
được bao nhiêu lần xuất sắc nhất round
đúng không? Thường lúc mình chơi số này
mình thấp lắm chỉ với 1 thôi. Cả trận
thường là 0 với 1 thôi. Mình ít khi cái
cột này của mình trên hai lắm đúng
không? Cho nên mình xuất nhất cái round
đấy đúng không? Hs% là cái gì các bạn
nhỉ? HS% là cái gì? HS% là cái gì? HS là
cái gì? Tỉ lệ gì đây? Phần trăm headsot
em bắn trúng đầu. Vì sao trong nhì sao
trong những game bán súng người ta lại
quan tâm đến cái tỉ lệ headsot hả các
bạn? Vì sao game bán súng mình lại quan
tâm?
>> Vì sao
>> nhiều điểm hơn?
>> Ừ ừ nhiều dam hơn dễ địch hơn đúng
không? Khó hơn đúng không? Khó hơn gây
được nhiều dam hơn dễ thết địch hơn.
Đúng rồi đúng không? Tất cả những cái gì
tinh túy nhất nó vào headsot đúng không?
Tinh túy nhất là vào headsot đúng không?
Thế đúng không? Bao nhiêu phần trăm
chưa? Ừ hơn đúng không? FO là điểm tổng.
Foil trong C nó tổ hợp của cái gì các
bạn nhở? Foil nó tổ hợp nhiều yếu tố lắm
đúng không? giết này, hỗ trợ này, gì nữa
các bạn? Có cái gì giúp các bạn tích lũy
được point nữa này. Trong một trận đấu
set go bây giờ là set 2 đúng không? Có
cái gì giúp các bạn cộng cái point lên
nhỉ? Các bạn giết được người các bạn hỗ
trợ này. Có cái gì nữa các bạn này. MVP.
Ừ, MVP hình như cũng cộng đúng không? Ừ,
cũng cộng. Gì nữa các bạn?
>> Đặt gỡ bom.
>> Đặt bom, gỡ bom đúng không? Loại là như
vậy. Rất nhiều thứ cộng lại đúng không?
Point thì mình cũng giữ đúng không? Càng
càng càng tốt đúng không? Và mình sẽ
muốn dự đoán c resort này đúng không?
Đấy, tức là gì? Mình phân tích qua một
lượt là mình đã loại bỏ được một vài
những cái feature rồi, một vài những cái
cột mà thấy chả liên quan gì rồi đúng
không? Tất nhiên trong quá trình chúng
ta huấn luyện chúng ta sẽ tính những cái
thứ thống kê khác sau đúng không?
Coration các thứ các thứ sau. Đấy nhưng
mà rõ ràng là gì? Là về mặt con người
chúng ta nhìn vào chúng ta đã có thể
chúng ta loại bỏ một vài những cái thông
tin chúng ta thấy là nó không quan trọng
rồi đúng không? Những thông tin chúng ta
biết chắc chắn rằng nó không nó không có
một tí ảnh hưởng gì đến kết quả chúng ta
sẽ bỏ nó đi đúng không?
Đấy thế đây là một bộ. Thế ngoài ra mình
sẽ có mình sẽ cho các bạn ba bộ. Mỗi bộ
mình đều cho các bạn hai loại file. Một
là file CV và hai là file Excel. Nội
dung y hệt nhau. Các bạn thích dùng file
nào cũng được. Đấy là một bộ. Một bộ nữa
là về hai bộ kia đều về bệnh. Một bộ nữa
là cũng là về bệnh tiểu đường. Một bệnh
nữa là về bệnh à tim nhá.
Các bạn lấy hết thì cũng được nhưng các
bạn tưởng tượng nhá. Nếu các bạn lấy hết
feature các bạn đưa vào trong mô hình ấy
thì nó giống như kiểu là một người giáo
viên ra hiệu sách mua hết sách về rồi
bắt học sinh mình học không có lọc gì cả
đúng không lọc xem là cái sách nào nó
phù hợp với học sinh mình sách nào nó
phù hợp với level của mình thì nó sẽ bắt
là khiến cho cái mô hình nó sẽ phải học
nó phân tán hơn nó sẽ không có sự tập
trung và những cái tài liệu quan trọng
đúng không nếu các bạn để nguyên các bạn
đưa vào mô hình ấy thì về mặt kỹ thuật
mô hình nó vẫn học được nhưng mà nó sao
không tốt bằng còn nếu chúng ta chúng ta
chủ can thiệp chúng ta lọc bớt những cái
thứ râu ria đi những thứ không quan
trọng đi thì mô hình các bạn nó sẽ học
tốt hơn đúng không Con người nào thì máy
nó cũng thế. Đúng rồi, còn lâu hơn nữa
đúng không? Đáng nhẽ là bây giờ anh mua
ở ngoài hiệu sách 10 quyển nhưng mà chỉ
có tám quyển tốt thôi. Lọc bỏ bớt hai
quyển đi thì học sinh nó học tập trung
hơn, tốn ít thời gian hơn. Thì bây giờ
các bạn lại bắt nó học cả đủ 10 quyển
thì vừa học phải những cái thứ nó dư
thừa lại vừa mất thời gian đúng không?
Đấy đúng không? Cái bước lòng này là
bước mà nó sẽ cần đến gọi là cái domain
knowledge của các bạn đúng không? Nó
không công thức nào cả. Thực sự là nó
không công thức nào cả. Chỉ đơn giản là
gì? là nếu tôi thấy là cái feature này
nó hoàn toàn nó chả liên quan gì cái tit
tôi không thể dựa vào nó để tôi dựa cái
tit đúng không nếu tôi là con người tôi
không dựa vào nó thì tôi dựng tit được
thì tôi bỏ đi. Còn nếu tôi vẫn dựa vào
nó được là tôi không có một cái lý do
vững chắc tôi lại bỏ đi tôi giữ lại ha.
Mình sẽ cho các bạn ba bộ nhá. Bộ này
một bộ về tiểu đường và một bộ về đột
quỵ. Được chưa? Một bộ về đột quỵ, bộ về
tiểu đường và bộ này. Các bạn chọn bộ
nào cũng được. Bài toán classification
rất là đơn giản. Các bạn chỉ chọc cái
cột là cái cái cột là cái thứ rời dạc ấ
đây là cái cột cái kết quả đúng không?
Là xong thì cho ba bộ các bạn các bạn
thử dựa vào cái giút chúng ta hôm nay
chúng ta học vào cái buổi trước đúng
không? Chúng ta xây dựng cái mù
classification cho bộ dibt rồi chúng ta
thử chúng ta xây dựng một cái mô hình
nữa đây nó sẽ khó hơn một chút bộ này
tại vì sao kết quả nó sẽ có ba kết quả
thắng hòa thua trước là chúng ta chỉ có
hai kết quả là tiểu đường với không thôi
nó sẽ hơi khó hơn một tí nhưng mà cách
làm thì vẫn tương tự như vậy. Cái này nó
sẽ hơi khó hơn một chút nữa là gì? Là
chúng ta có một cái cột này là cột không
phải dạng dạng số. Buổi tuần sau, buổi
thứ bảy, chúng ta sẽ học cách chúng ta
xử lý cái categorical feature này đúng
không? Nhưng mà các bạn thử về các bạn
thử tìm hiểu xem xem làm thế nào nhá.
Như
ok
hôm nay chúng ta phải có khoảng bảy v tự
hành cơ. Hôm nay mới hôm nay chúng mới
xong cái bài đầu tiên đúng không? Chúng
thấy là reaction là một cái nữa này. NLP
là một cái này. Computer vision là một
cái này. C là một cái này.
Recommendation system là một cái nữa
nhá.
Giả sử nhá. Giả sử các bạn không bỏ nhá.
Thì hai cột này các bạn có thể xử lý
theo kiểu là các bạn dùng nó là kiểu
numer feature thôi. Numic feature cái
year này cũng có thể làm như vậy. Và cái
này các bạn có thể các bạn lấy tất cả
các bạn mà các bạn chú ý cái di này vấn
đề là giả sử nó có nhiều năm này nhá.
Các bạn có thể lấy tất cả các bạn trừ đi
cái 5 min. Ví dụ 5 min năm 2015 các bạn
trừ đi xong các bạn coi nó là dạng số
thôi đúng không? 0 1 2 3 4 kiểu kiểu như
vậy. Được chưa? Có ba cột này rồi thì
không cần không cần không cần cái cột
này nữa. Cái cột de mania này nữa đúng
không? Còn nếu các bạn chỉ có cái cột
này thôi các bạn phải tách nó ra thành
ba cột riêng. Được chưa?
Ngày xử lý riêng, tháng xử lý riêng, năm
xử lý riêng. Được chưa?
Team m tức là gì? Tức là tức là team A
team B thắng được bao nhiêu round? Một
trận là maximum là 30 round. Thế nhưng
mà team nào mà lên 16 trước thì là nó
hết đúng không? Ví dụ này 16 13 này tổng
có tổng là đã phải 30 đâu nhưng mà nó
hết trận rồi. Bỏ đi. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
đây là cái thứ mà
nó không lại thông tin gì cả. Tại vì có
cái ví dụ là nó là team A, có ví dụ nó
là team B đúng không? Và đây là cái
thông tin mà sau khi chúng ta hết trận
rồi chúng ta phải có đúng không? Chúng
ta muốn ví dụ là xây dựng một cái hình
sao trong trận nó đang tiếp diễn là tôi
có thể tư dự đoán xem là phần trăm thắng
của cầu cái player này khả năng thắng
cao hơn thua cao hơn đúng mà. Đây là các
bạn hết trận rồi nó mới có cái cột này
được chưa? Đấy mà trong cái hàng đầu thì
ông này thuộc team A, hàng sau này thu
team B đúng không? Không dựa nó để biết
thắng hay thua được. Tất nhiên dựa nó
thì biết hòa thì được thế nhưng mà không
biết nó thắng hay thua được.
Đúng rồi, chính xác. Chính xác nhá. Một
là bộ này, hai là bộ đ cái bộ DBT trông
như thế này này.
Bộ DBT trông như thế này đây. Đấy, nó sẽ
hơi khác cái bộ DBT của chúng ta một
chút. Nó sẽ như này, nó khác một tí, nó
nhiều thông tin hơn. Được chưa? Nó sẽ có
hai cột. Một là dự đoán bị tiểu đường,
hai là bị béo phỉ. Các bạn có thể dự
đoán một trong hai cột hoặc các bạn có
thể dự đoán cả hai nhá. Nếu các bạn muốn
khó một chút, các bạn dự đoán giúp mình
thử dự đoán cả hai đi. Vừa dự đoán tiểu
đường vừa dự đoán béo phỉ. Đây là bộ về
tiểu đường. Còn bộ nữa về đột quỵ. Bộ
đột quỵ nó trông như này. Quỵ cũng ná đá
thế thôi. Đây đột quỵ đây. Đấy nó cột
cột cuối à không phải cột đột quỵ đâu ấy
nhỉ?
Cột đây. Stop đây. Strop là đột quỵ đây.
Một là bị không là không sao cả. Chưa
ừ bệnh thì
từ dom nó mới knowledge các bạn thôi.
Mình cũng không có kiến thức nhiều về
lĩnh vực y khoai đâu. Mình cũng không rõ
lắm. Nếu chúng ta không rõ thì chúng ta
giữ thôi. Điểu không? Thì chúng ta chắc
chắn chúng ta mới bỏ đâu. Ừ. Ví dụ như
mình thường là về về healthc thì thường
thì mình sẽ giữ tại vì mình chả biết là
cái nào quan trọng cái nào không.
Rồi sau này khi mà các bạn đi làm các
bạn ví dụ các bạn làm trong lĩnh vực y
tế các bạn làm data song trong lĩnh vực
y tế bây gi các bạn sẽ có nhiều kiến
thức hơn các bạn sẽ biết là à với những
cái bài toán này tôi cần cái thông tin
gì tôi cần cái gì tôi không cần đó không
hẳn học thêm mà lúc các bạn đi làm ấy là
các bạn tự trong cái môi trường các bạn
sẽ học từ đồng nghiệp ấy mà không cái
này không cần phải đi học lớp gì cả chỉ
khi nào các bạn đi làm các bạn chính các
bạn là người trong cái công ty đấy các
bạn mới học được nhá
chưa hôm nay mình sẽ up cho các bạn cái
đoạn s hôm Th nhưng mà mình vẫn recomm
các bạn thì các bạn cố gắng tự mình code
theo ý hiểu của mình nhá. Tự mình code
theo ý hiểu của mình. Cái đó mình squip
mình dùng để tham khảo thôi nhá. Có gì
chưa chắc có gì chưa rõ các bạn cứ hỏi
mình
nhá. Tuần sau cả hai buổi chúng ta vẫn
full thực hành các bạn nhá. Tuần sau cả
hai buổi vẫn full thực hành. Được chưa?
Từ giờ đến cuối khóa phần cái phần lý
thuyết chủ yếu làở đầu khóa rồi. Phần
cuối khóa này chúng ta sẽ ít lý thuyết
thôi. Chủ yếu là thực hành nhá.
Ok. Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Th nhá.
Tuần sau chúng ta học tiếp các bạn nhá.
Chúc các bạn buổi tối vui vẻ. Chúc các
bạn tuần mới học tập và làm việc hiệu
quả các bạn nhá. Cảm ơn mọi người rất là
nhiều nha. Mình sẽ up cho các bạn. Hình
như mình mình up rồi. Mình up rồi. Trong
cái mình có một cái phet ấy mình up hết
rồi nhá. Nó sẽ có ba bộ đâ này. Được
chưa nhá. Mỗi một cái bộ này sẽ có một
cái file hướng dẫn. Một cái file TXT
hướng dẫn. Các bạn có thể mở ra các bạn
sẽ hướng dẫn qua một chút nhá. Cảm ơn
mọi người nhiều nha. Cảm ơn mọi người
nhiều nha. Bye mọi người nha. Tối vui vẻ
nha.
Bye mọi người nha.